projet de loi immigration c'est vers la
droite et le centre que le gouvernement
a trouvé des majorités absolues l'année
dernière Tam merci merci beaucoup
Quentin pour toutes ces explications
vous parlez de la majorité de la droite
et du centre et nous sommes justement
avec le président du groupe de l'Union
centriste au Sénat président de l'UDI
Hervé Marseille bonjour bonjour Hervé
Marseille Gabriel Atal hier s'est donc
exprimé à l'Assemblée nationale il a
repris des thèmes cher à la droite la
fermeté sur le régalien la défense de la
valeur travail la dénonciation de
l'écologie punitive est-ce que c'est un
discours auquel vous adhérez écoutez ça
va dans le bon sens en tous les cas
c'est très encourageant et évidemment je
crois que notre pays a besoin d'avoir un
gouvernement qui réussisse avec l'aide
du Parlement parce que si nous échouons
et bien nous savons ce qui nous attend
en 2027 ça vous a séduit donc ce
discours vous attendez les actes
j'imagine voilà je je veux dire les mots
sont là ils sont posés les objectifs
aussi maintenant il faut réaliser et je
crois que le gouvernement aura besoin du
Parlement et singulièrement du Sénat
Quentin vient de dire à l'instant que
nous avions été indispensabl pour faire
aboutir le texte sur les retraites
indispensable pour faire aboutir le
texte sur l'immigration et bien si on
veut réussir on a besoin du Sénat alors
vous parlez du texte sur l'immigration
qui a été adopté au mois de décembre
hier Gabriel hatal a annoncé une réforme
par réglementaire de l'aide médicale
d'État réformer l'aide médicale d'État
ça faisait partie du contrat passé entre
la droite et notamment la droite
sénatoriale et sa prédéceuse ellisabeth
borne est-ce que cela vous convient une
réforme par voie
réglementaire j'aurais préféré
évidemment qu'on puisse en débattre je
comprends parfaitement que le
gouvernement préfère se limiter à la
voie réglementaire c'était l'option de
toute façon qui était dans la lettre que
Madame borne avait envoyé au président
du Sénat ou rglaire alors évidemment le
gouvernement a choisi une solution qui
est beaucoup plus favorable c'est la
voie réglementaire on verra le moment
venu vous le vous le déplorez quand même
ça aurait été mieux un passage devant le
Parlement même si c'était risqué cont
tenu vous vous le savez de de de la
complexité qu'il y a eu à aborder un
certain nombre de textes l'année
dernière encore une fois l'essentiel
c'est qu'on aille sur le sujet laame
parce qu'il y a un véritable problème
maintenant
ça aurait été beaucoup mieux qu'on
puisse en discuter si ça passe par la
voie réglementaire on verra comment ça
se passe vous n'utilisez pas les mots de
LR Eric cotti a parlé lui de trahison de
la parole donnée on sent que vous vous
différenciez clairement de LR sur ce
sujet écoutez la droite et la droite le
centre est le centre donc j'emploie les
mots du centre nous avons une vision
beaucoup plus
modéré dans nos
appréciations je crois que nous nous ne
cherchons pas à donner 1500 € aux
agriculteurs parce que c'est impossible
on ne dénonce pas le Conseil
constitutionnel dans les mêmes termes je
crois qu'il faut raison garder et il y a
des mots qu'il ne faut pas employer il
reste vos alliés notamment au Sénat nous
formons une majorité ici au Sénat je
crois que nous essayons de trouver les
compromis indispensables sur les textes
il faudra ensemble avec LR et avec le
gouvernement essayer de faire avancer
les dossiers alors RV Marseille on va
aussi s'intéresser bien sûr au programme
de cet après-midi qu'est-ce que vous
attendez du discours du premier ministre
tout à l'heure et bien qu'il donne
davantage de précision concernant un
sujet qui nous é chè c'est-à-dire les
territoires la
décentralisation les moyens donnés aux
collectivités et pour ma part je lui
rappellerai dans dans mon propos que si
on fait des choses et il annonce des des
des points pertinents pour les logements
il y a une vraie crise du logement qui a
besoin d'être lancé et puis il y a un
sujet qu' n'a pas abordé c'est la
dépendance nous sommes dans un pays qui
vieillit la situation est assez
explosive et nous
av oui d'accord mais enfin on a besoin
vraiment de mettre la gomme ça fait des
années des années qu'on attend et et
puis dernier point la dette parce qu'on
en a peu parlé nous avons 3000 plus de
3000 milliards de dettes c'est quelque
chose que nous laissons à nos enfants
pour l'avenir qui Auer nos marges de
manœuvre et nous avons besoin d'avoir
davantage de visibilité sur les
économies qui seront réalisé message
adressé aussi à l'ancien ministre des
comptes publques qui a été brièvement
Gabriel alors comme président du groupe
Union centriste comme président de l'UDI
est-ce que vous vous sentez aujourd'hui
plus macro compatible aujourd'hui
qu'hier le problème n'est pas de savoir
si on est Macron compatible ou pas le
problème c'est de savoir si on arrive à
trouver des solutions sachant qu'il n'y
a pas de majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale et que c'est au Sénat qui a
une responsabilité parlementaire où on
doit construire des solutions comme on
l'a fait à différentes reprises donc le
problème est pas savoir si il est bon de
faire ou de pas faire avec les uns ou
avec les autres le problème c'est de
trouver des solutions pour répondre à
l'attente des franç VO doute aujourd'hui
euh dans la situation de crise dans
laquelle nous sommes il y a des des
agriculteurs sur les routes euh il y a
un problème de pouvoir d'achat il y a la
guerre en Ukraine en Arménie au
Moyen-Orient et je crois qu'on a plus
les moyens simplement d'utiliser des
mots de dénoncer qui Bruxelles qui le
Conseil constitutionnel ou je ne sais
qui euh il nous faut trouver des
solutions donc il faut chercher des
solutions collectives vous parlez de
Bruxelles une toute dernière question
vous pourriez partir avec les
macronistes pour les élections
européennes c'est dans quelques mois
maintenant pourquoi pas pourquoi pas la
porte est grande ouverte en tous les cas
c'est une solution pertinente merci
beaucoup merci Hervé Marseille d'avoir
répondu à mes questions on va tout de
suite retrouver Quentin Calmet dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat Quentin bien pour
savoir tout simplement comment ça va se
passer cet après-midi juste une petite
image th on voit rachidti qui est en
train de s'installer est ici à la droite
du nouveau Premier ministre Gabriel Atal
et effectivement on va voir quelle sera
la durée du discours de Gabriel atthal
s'il fera un discours plus court que les
1h20 d'hier à l'Assemblée nationale
ensuite tous les présidents de groupe
vont prendre la parole à tour de rôle
dans l'ordre d'importance numérique des
groupes politiques les lesr qui sont
ainsi le plus grand nombre de sénateurs
seront les premiers avec une déclaration
de bruneo retaillot après le discours de
politique général de Gabriel Atal pour
14 minutes puis les socialistes puis les
centristes Hervé Marseille que l'on
vient d'entendre à votre micro t ensuite
Renaissance et cetera et cetera et à la
fin de cette séquence Gabriel Atal
répondra aux différents orateurs cela
donc devrait durer cette séance jusqu'à
17h30 alors que le président Gérard
Larcher est en train d'arriver ici dans
l'hémicycle de la chambre haute du
parlement pour cette déclaration de
politique générale de Gabriel Atal qui
est à suivre dans les toutes prochaines
secondes puisque maintenant les
sénateurs sont installés le Gouvernement
est également sur le ban des ministres
ça va pouvoir commencer d'un instant à
l'autre sans plus attendre direction la
séance oui effectivement Gérard Larché
que l'on voit s'installer au plateau
après la galerie des bustes Gabriel
hatal va donc s'exprimer d'ici quelques
instants hier le nouveau Premier
ministre a dit vouloir déverrouiller
dmicardiser
déburocratiser la France est-ce que ça
va être encore dans son discours
aujourd'hui devant la Chambre haute
est-ce que son disc on va comporter les
mêmes mots qu'ell vont être ces
inflexions face au Sénat on prend tout
suite la direction de l'hémicycle avec
le président du Sénat reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en séance
je n'en vois point le procèsverbal est
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
l'ordre du jour appelle une déclaration
du gouvernement suivie d'un débat en
application de l'article 50-1 de la
Constitution monsieur le Premier
ministre vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs lorsque le Sénat est faible la
République est faible lorsque le Sénat
est fort la République est forte et
lorsqu'il n'y a pas
[Applaudissements]
et lorsqu'il n'y a et lorsqu'il n'y a
pas de Sénat il n'y a plus de
République ces mots ces mots ce ne sont
pas les
miens mais je l'ai fait mien mais je
l'ai fait
mien ce sont ceux du recteur préot h
homme de droit de conviction et sénateur
aux premières années de notre 5e
République ces mots je le dis je les
fait mien le Sénat est la chambre de la
réflexion et du long terme c'est la
chambre du débat d'idées et de la
construction de compromis c'est la
chambre du respect de nos institutions
comme des convictions c'est la voie des
territoires des élus des préoccupations
du quotidien je n'imagine pas la
République sans le bicamérisme et plus
encore dans une période de crise dans
une période où les événements se
multiplient et les défis s'additionnent
nous avons besoin du Sénat besoin de sa
capacité à incarner à la fois la hauteur
de vue et la proximité avec les Français
m'adresser à vous c'est m'adresser à
tous nos territoires de l'hexagone et
des outremè dans leur unité et leur
singularité m'adresser à vous c'est
aussi affirmer la volé du gouvernement
de travailler et de construire en commun
au sein de mon équipe pourtant la plus
resserrée de la 5e République je compte
un ancien sénateur avec Christophe Béchu
un sénateur actuel aujourd'hui au
gouvernement avec Sébastien le Cornu je
compte des maires qui savent
l'engagement la passion mais aussi les
contraintes qu'exige ce mandat je compte
avec Catherine vaterin notamment avec ti
pour la mairie du 7e arrondissement je
compte des élus locaux j'en suis
moi-même un depuis 10 ans des élus
locaux qui aiment leur territoire comme
ils aiment notre pays et veulent
s'engager pour lui ensemble à la tête de
cette équipe je viens devant vous
aujourd'hui prêt à m'engager m'engager à
travailler avec le Sénat sur tous les
textes et dans toutes les circonstances
j'y ai tenu comme ministre des comptes
publics comme ministre de l'éducation
nationale j'y tiens aujourd'hui comme
premier ministre et nous le ferons avec
l'ensemble de mon gouvernement je
m'engage à avancer à l'écoute de nos
élus et de nos territoires derrière le
cap fixé par le président de la
République c'est à leur contact que j'ai
aussi construit les constats et les
solutions de ma déclaration de politique
générale c'est avec eux que je veux
gouverner et décider je serai un premier
ministre de terrain à la tête d'un
gouvernement de terrain je m'engage
enfin à agir toujours pour la
simplification le bon sens et le
quotidien des Français que nous disent
les élus que nous disent nos concitoyens
que nous disent les agriculteurs ces
derniers jours qu'il croulent trop sous
les règles sous les normes qui les
brident les brim et empêche notre pays
d'avancer alors ma méthode sera simple
dialoguer écouter et décider décider de
mesures claires et compréhensibles
décider pour que les choses changent
vraiment toujours pour les Français
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs le
cri de colère exprimé par nos
agriculteurs ces derniers jours est le
reflet des doutes des exaspérations des
colères mais aussi des espoirs et des
opportunités de notre pays la France est
une grande patrie agricole l'agriculture
fait partie de l'âme de notre pays elle
fait partie de nos racines de notre
héritage chaque territoire son emblème
qui fait écho aux cultures et aux
élevages et si les mots pays et paysans
se ressemblent tant c'est parce que l'un
ne va pas sans l'autre je n'imagine pas
la France sans son agriculture et la
France ne serait pas la France sans ses
agriculteurs pourtant nos agriculteurs
souffrent ils incarnent tous les défis
d'une France qui doute ils sont le
visage du travail et du dévouement ils
ne connaissent ni vacances ni véritable
repos et pourtant leur rémunération
n'est pas toujours à la hauteur de leur
engagement à la hauteur de de ce qu'ils
apportent à notre pays alors oui tous
les Français des classes moyennes se
reconnaissent en eux tous ces Français
qui ne peuvent compter que sur leur
travail mais doivent compter chaque euro
à la fin du mois nos agriculteurs sont
les premières victimes du dérèglement
climatique ils subissent le gel la
sécheresse les inondations les tempêtes
alors oui toute notre société se
retrouve dans leurs inquiétudes nos
agriculteurs croulent sous les normes
chacune de leurs initiatives peut
relever du parcours du combattant
chacune de leurs actions est réglementé
et surréglementé alors oui chacun de nos
concitoyens partage leur volonté de
respirer de se débarrasser de procédures
inutiles de voir leurs initiatives
libérer de la bureaucratie nos
agriculteurs s'interrogent sur le
fonctionnement de l'Union européenne ils
savent ce que la PAC leur apporte mais
n'accepte pas plus que nous certaines de
ces lourdeurs alors oui nos compatriotes
s'identifient à cette interrogation nos
compatriotes qui savent très bien que
nous sommes plus forts grâce à l'Europe
mais exigent que l'Union européenne soit
plus proche plus efficace et plus
protectrice je le dis sans détour nous
devons aussi prendre notre part j'en
prends l'engagement nous ne
surtransposerons pas les normes
européennes nous
devons être au côté de nos agriculteurs
et nous ne pouvons pas nous-mêmes leur
mettre des boulets au pied dans une
compétition européenne et mondiale car
nos agriculteurs aspirent à la
souveraineté ils s'indignent de la
concurrence déloyal de ceux qui ne rest
pas les mêmes standards de qualité que
nous ils aspirent à construire notre
indépendance agricole et alimentaire et
ils ont raison alors cet appel avec le
président de la République avec mon
gouvernement nous l'entendons nous y
répondons et je sais qu'il rejoint celui
de 68 millions de Français qui veulent
une France plus forte plus indépendante
plus souveraine enfin ce cré de colère
de nos agriculteurs est aussi un appel à
la
reconnaissance face à ceux qui n'ont eu
de cess ces dernières années de les
traiter comme des pollueurs comme des
bandits comme des bourreaux à ceux qui
en font des boucs émissaires faciles et
leur prêtent tous les mots là encore nos
compatriotes se retrouvent dans cette
volonté de reconnaissance ils refusent
de se résigner au déclin que promettent
les fatalistes et les oiseaux de mauvais
augure ils veulent agir défendre notre
identité et défendre la France mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs sous l'gide
du président de la République avec mon
gouvernement avec vous je veux restaurer
cette fierté française je veux répondre
aux inquiétudes de nos compatriotes une
à une sans exception je veux que le
travail paye plus et paye mieux
notamment pour nos concitoyens de classe
moyenne je veux débureaucratiser notre
pays simplifier la vie déverrouiller les
initiatives améliorer le quotidien je
veux porter une souveraineté nationale
et européenne construire une France plus
juste et plus libre dans une Europe plus
forte je veux que chaque française que
chaque Français puisse être fier de son
pays que chacun sache qu'il il a
pleinement le contrôle de sa vie et que
la France a pleinement son destin en
main cette ambition c'est celle portée
par le Président de la République et les
gouvernement d'Édouard Philippe de Jean
Castex et d'éliisabeth borne depuis 2017
c'est celle que portera mon gouvernement
avec pour seul cap de donner des
résultats pour les Français comme le
veut la coutume républicaine vous avez
entendu hier la lecture de ma
déclaration de politique générale à
l'Assemblée nationale et je remercie
Bruno Lemaire de l'avoir dans ses
moindres
[Applaudissements]
détails je souhaite devant vous revenir
sur les grands combats qui animeront mon
gouvernement vous avez entendu la
lecture de ma déclaration hier je ne
reviendrai pas dans l'ensemble des
détails de ce qui a été abordé à
l'Assemblée nationale hier l'important
est quand même que nous puissions avoir
un échange que je puisse vous entendre
et surtout vous répondre mais je veux
rappeler qu'à l'écoute des Français des
forces politiques des partenaires
sociaux des des élus locaux et de nos
concitoyens j'ai pensé et bâti de
première réponse parce que parler au
français c'est d'abord entendre une
exaspération celle je le disais il y a
un instant de ces Français de classe
moyenne trop paisé pour bénéficier des
aides pas assez pour être à l'aise et
qui ne peuvent compter que sur leur
travail c'est français qui demandent que
le travail paye plus et toujours mieux
que l'inactivité parler au français
c'est entendre un doute sur nos services
publics sur le respect de l'autorité
dans notre société la crainte du recul
et de l'éloignement pour la santé
l'éducation la sécurité pour toutes les
procédures du quotidien la crainte du
déclin de servicees publics qui ne
seraiit plus à la hauteur alors même que
l'on travaille dur et que l'on paye des
impôts pour les financer la crainte
d'une France à deux vitesses où les
classes moyennes et la France modeste
n'auraient plus accès à des services de
qualité une France où trop de nos
concitoyens ont le sentiment de ne pas
en avoir pour leurs impôts parler au
français enfin c'est parler de
transition écologique qu'il s'agisse de
jeunes qui s'engagent pour défendre la
planète des habitants du pas decalais
victime d'inondation pour la deuxième
fois en quelques mois ou des
agriculteurs que j'ai rencontré dans
leurô ou en hautegaron en indrélois tous
ont voulu m'interpeller sur le
dérèglement climatique et tous veulent
agir nous partons d'un bilan solide
depuis 2017 sous lesgit du président de
la République nous avons mené des
réformes fortes qui avaient trop attendu
pour libérer le marché du travail nous
en avons mené plusieurs ensemble encore
ces derniers mois je pense notamment à
la réforme de l'assurance chômage ou à
la réforme des retraites aujourd'hui de
premiers résultats arrivent le chômage
est à son niveau le plus bas depuis 25
ans 2 millions d'emplois ont été créés
on crée désormais plus d'emplois
industriels qu'on en supprime dans notre
pays on ouvre plus d'usines qu'on
enferme dans notre pays évidemment c'est
un début et ça n'efface pas encore des
années de désindustrialisation mais les
premiers résultats les premiers signaux
sont là nous inversons la tendance nous
ampli notre action sur l'apprentissage
il y avait avant l'élection du Président
de la République un peu moins de 300000
jeunes en apprentissage chaque année
nous sommes à 850000 jeunes en
apprentissage cette année et nous
approchons du million de jeunes en
apprentissage depuis 2017 nous avons
entamé le redressement de nos services
publics nous avons investi des montants
historiques pour l'hôpital nous avons
engagé des réformes fortes pour notre
éducation et revaloriser les professeurs
nous avons renforcé notre état régalien
avec les investissements sans précédent
pour notre sécurité notre justice et nos
armées nous avons agi aussi pour les
services publics de proximité pour
veiller à ce que chacun y ait accès et
nous avons maillé le territoire d'espace
France service ils sont la porte ouverte
aux démarches de nos concitoyens pour
tous où que ce soit enfin le rythme de
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre a
baissé l'année dernière comme il n'avait
jamais baissé dans notre pays en moyenne
nos émission de gaz à effet de ser
baissé d'1 % par an avant 2017 dans le
premier quinquenat du président de la
République elles ont baissé de 2 % par
an en moyenne l'an dernier sur les 9
premiers mois de l'année elles ont
baissé de près de 5 % j'y vois la preuve
que lorsqu'on investit massivement
plutôt que de punir et de brutaliser nos
concitoyens lorsqu'on investit qu'on
accompagne des secteurs économiques des
entreprises et des industries
particulièrement polluantes qu'on les
aide à se décarboner ça produit des
résultats et ça nous permet d'aller plus
vite plus loin que de chercher à punir à
taxer et à
brutaliser cette planification se
construira avec les territoires j'y
reviendrai elle s'adaptera aux défis et
aux besoins de chacun une fois que j'ai
dit tout ça je suis parfaitement lucide
sur le fait que nous n'avons pas réglé
tous les problèmes qu'il reste
évidemment des difficultés dans notre
pays qu'il y a des Français qui
souffrent qu'il y a des Français qui
doutent qu'il y a des Français qui
attendent qu'il y a même des Français
qui n'attendent plus rien parce qu'ils
n'y croient plus je suis conscient du
chemin qu'il reste à parcourir à
parcourir pour restaurer la confiance à
parcourir pour arrivé à ce dernier
kilomètre qui fait que lorsque nous
annonçons des choses ça puisse se
traduire très concrètement dans le
quotidien des Français et je le dis de
ce point de vue le premier de mes
combats restera celui du travail agir
pour le travail c'est d'abord agir pour
veiller à ce que ceux qui travaill
gagnent toujours plus que ceux qui ne
travaillent pas agir pour le travail
c'est veiller à ce que l'on gagne mieux
sa vie et offrir des perspectives
d'évolution à chacun c'est aussi
résoudre ce paradoxe qui veut qu'avec un
chômage autour de 7 % il reste des
centaines de milliers d'emplois non
pourvus sur le territoire aussi nous
agirons autour de trois piliers
dmicardisés déverrouillé
débureaucratisé un travail a été entamé
vous le savez pour qu'il n'y ait plus de
branchees professionnelles qui
rémunèrent en dessous du SMIC nous
allons le poursuivre et nous prendrons
toutes les mesures nécessaires pour
qu'il puisse aboutir un très grand
travail a été
entamé ensuite il y a tous ces Français
qui sont au SMIC ou légèrement au-dessus
du SMIC nous avons ces der dernière
décennies concentrer les exonérations de
cotisation concentrer des dispositifs de
soutien notamment via la prime
d'activité autour du SMIC et la réalité
Bruno Le Maire l'a lu hier dans mon
discours c'est qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a
plus beaucoup d'intérêt pour personne à
augmenter le salaire de salariés proche
du SMIC parce que l'employeur doit payer
beaucoup plus de cotisation sociale
parce que le salarié lui-même perd de sa
prime d'activité voit sa CSG augmenter
et bien souvent entre dans l'impôt sur
le revenu il faut sortir de ce que
certains techniquement appellent ce coin
fiscalo social qui concentre trop de
Français autour du SMIC nous avons un
SMIC supérieur à celui de nos voisins et
c'est une chance mais nous avons
beaucoup plus de salariés qui sont
proches du SMIC que chez les pays
voisins parce que nous avons cette forme
de trappe dont nous devons sortir des
travaux ont été engagés des propositions
ont été faites par des parlementaires
par un certain nombre d'experts par des
partenaires sociaux je souhaite que dans
les prochains textes financiers nous
amorcions cette évolution je veux
également que nous puissions avancer
s'agissant de la rémunération des
fonctionnaires rendre leur carrière plus
attractive en favorisant l'engagement et
le mérite plutôt que la seule ancienneté
un projet de loi sera présenté en ce
sens dès ce second semestre je veux
avancer pour nos indépendants pour pour
poursuivre la réforme de l'assiette
sociale permettant à des millions
d'artisans de commerçants d'agriculteurs
de profession libéral de acquérir
d'acquérir davantage de droits sociaux
notamment à la retraite sans payer
davantage de cotisation notre deuxième
objectif c'est de déverrouiller le
travail en incitant à l'activité en
accompagnant vers le marché du travail
ce qui en sont exclus c'est le sens de
l'expérimentation du RSA accompagné de
15 heur d'activité pour l'insertion 18
départements étaient concernés ils
seront 47 le mois prochain et nous
généraliserons ce dispositif d'ici au
1er janvier 2025 à l'ensemble du
territoire c'est le sens de notre
volonté d'aller plus loin dans la
réforme de l'assurance chômage nous
devons faire preuve de responsabilité
d'audace et d'ambition inciter toujours
plus à la reprise du travail c'est le
sens de notre volonté de supprimer
toutes les trappes à inactivité et je
l'assume notamment à l'allocation de
solidarité spécifique qui prolonge les
aides après la fin de l'assurance
chômage qui permet de valider des
trimestres de retraite alors que nous
considérons que la retraite ça doit
toujours être le fruit d'années de
trimestr de travail et non d'allocation
sociale nous la supprimerons
progressivement mais déverrouiller le
travail c'est aussi faire en sorte que
chacun touche ce à quoi il a droit c'est
le sens de la solidarité à la source
nous allons poursuivre ce chantier
déverrouiller le travail c'est l'adapter
aux évolutions des attentes et des
aspirations de nos concitoyens
l'équilibre vie personnelle vie
professionnelle la question des horaires
des méthodes de management de
télétravail sont autant de défis
auxquels nous devons répondre je
souhaite que l'État soit exemplaire
puisse proposer comme je l'ai fait à
Bercy de nouvelles organisations en
expérimentant pour nos agents publics
déverrouiller le travail c'est libérer
notre économie au printemps nous
examinerons un projet de loi en ce sens
je souhaite qu'il puisse permettre de
déverrouiller un certain nombre de
professions comme l'avait fait à
l'époque la fameuse loi Macron enfin
déverrouiller le travail c'est permettre
à chacun d'accéder à un logement car
sans logement abordable il est
impossible d'accéder à un emploi mais
bien plus largement le logement c'est
une des matrices de notre société c'est
la voie ouverte à une vie digne c'est la
confiance trouvée pour beaucoup de
Français de classe moyenne qui voi dans
le fait de bénéficier d'un logement
d'être propriétaire de son logement un
des éléments d'une retraite sereine pour
l'avenir nous voulons avancer pour un
choc d'offre grâce à la simplification
des normes notamment en revoyant les DPE
en simplifiant la densification en
levant certaines contraintes de zonage
grâce à la désignation d'ici quelques
semaines de 20 territoires engagés pour
le logement où les procédures seront
toutes accéléré nous nous y créerons
30000 nouveaux logements d'ici 3 ans
nous créerons ce choc d'offre en
assumant de réquisitionner des bâtiments
vide notamment des bâtiments de bureau
nous le créerons en soutenant le
logement social grâce à un nouveau prêt
de long terme pour acheter du foncier 2
milliards d'euros distribué par la
banque des territoires évidemment ce que
je propose ici n'est qu'un début pour
continuer à bâtir à construire continuer
à permettre à tous ceux qui le
souhaitent de devenir propriétaire nous
irons plus loin plus loin pour soutenir
la construction plus lo pour soutenir
les Français qui veulent devenir ou
rester propriétair plus loin pour loger
un certain nombre d'agents publics qui
assure notamment notre sécurité notre
santé et l'éducation de nos enfants qui
doivent avoir une forme de priorité dans
l'accès à un certain nombre de logements
sociaux plus loin pour faire du logement
des Français un facteur de bien-être
pour tous et pour chacun alors nous
allons proposer de faire évoluer la loi
SRU en répondant ainsi à des attentes
anciennes et récurrentes des élus locaux
d'une part les mairesont la main pour la
première attribution des logements
sociaux dans leur
[Applaudissements]
commune d'autre part nous proposons que
les logements intermédiaires accessibles
à la classe moyenne soit désormais
inclus dans le calcul de la part de
logement social dans le cadre de la loi
SRU je veux le dire aussi clairement à
ceux qui s'inquiètent dans les communes
soumises à la loi maintiendront
évidemment une exigence d'un nombre
minimal de logements très sociaux enfin
à la veille des 70 ans de l'appel de
l'abé pierre je veux rappeler ici
l'engagement de mon gouvernement à
lutter contre le mal
logement un logement digne c'est le
fondement d'une vie digne nous y
travaillerons une proposition de loi
pour lutter contre lescopropriété
dégradé a été adopté à la quasi
unanimité à l'Assemblée nationale je
suis sûr que nous pouvons travailler
ensemble au Sénat pour faire avancer ce
combat nous y travaillerons en
continuant à soutenir l'hébergement
d'urgence je rappelle à ceux qui nous
interpelle que lorsque le président de
la République a été élu en 2017 il y
avait à peine une centaine de milliers
de logements dans les de places dans
l'ébergement d'urgence nous avons doublé
les places dans l'hébergement d'urgence
nous sommes aujourd'hui à 200000 places
nous n'avons pas de leçons à
recevoir Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs notre troè
priorité
oui je vous savez hier à l'Assemblée
nationale ils y sont allés très fort
j'ai quand même déroulé mon discours
donc je le déroulerai ici même si on
m'interpelle justement on va vous
écouter Monsieur le Premier Ministre
notre trème priorité c'est de
déburaucratiser la société les
agriculteurs les élus locaux les
entrepreneurs les indépendants et les
artisans comme tous ceux qui créent de
l'emploi sur notre sol comme tous ceux
qui agissent nous le disent il y a trop
de règles trop de normes trop de
procédures qui les brim et parfois brise
leurs initiatives alors face à la
bureaucratisation il y a une réponse
simple elle s'appelle la simplification
à l'automne nous engagerons une nouvelle
étape de la réforme du droit du travail
pour simplifier la vie de nos
entrepreneurs le quotidien de nos PME et
de nos TPE nous allons également
simplifier nos procédures pour amplifier
encore la réindustrialisation nous avons
beaucoup invancé avec la loi industrie
verte mais il faut aller plus loin il
n'est pas normal qu'il faille deux fois
plus de temps pour sortir un projet
industriel en France qu'en Allemagne
cela limite nos possibilités
d'investissement étranger sur notre pays
une fois qu'on a dit ça monsieur le
rapporteur général ususson on prend un
certain nombre de mesures pour continuer
à réduire les délais comme nous l'avons
fait dans la loi industrie verte nous
présenterons une deuxième loi industrie
verte pour aller encore plus loin j'ai
donné une première piste hier à
l'Assemblée nationale notamment centrer
le travail de la CNDP sur les très
grands projets d'envergure nationale
pour libérer un grand nombre de projets
de la procédure de la CNDP ce qui fera
gagner 6 mois dans certaines procédures
pour avancer la déburaucratisation doit
toucher tous les secteurs aujourd'hui
chaque Français dans ses démarche dans
son activité peut mesurer combien notre
pays est à quel point nous
pourrions faire mieux et plus vite tous
les sujets sont sur la table pour
simplifier accélérer faciliter la vie
des français et je le dis ici ce travail
de
débureaucratisation nous le ferons en
premier lieu avec les maires parce que
les maires sont très concernés dans leur
vie quotidienne dans leur action
quotidienne en tant qu'élu mais ils sont
aussi les témoins de toutes ces
complexités parce que bien souvent des
Français des entrepreneurs des
agriculteurs qui font face à ces
complexités dans les normes dans les
procédures ils viennent avant tout en
parler à leurs Mair c'est les maires je
crois sont les plus lucides ceux qui ont
la vision la plus exhaustive de toutes
ces contraintes de tous ces freins dans
la vie de nos concitoyens c'est donc
avec eux que nous construirons des
solutions pour eux-mêmes pour les élus
mais aussi pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens et ils seront je crois aussi
des por-voies de nos concitoyens nous
allons déverrouiller désmicardiser
débureaucratiser dans un seul objectif
réarmer notre pays assurer sa
souveraineté permettre à chacun d'avoir
son destin en main pour cela et je sais
combien vous y êtes attentif nous devons
faire preuve d'une responsabilité
budgétaire absolue la dette publique est
une épée de damoclesè au-dessus de notre
modèle social au-dessus de la capacité à
agir des jeunes générration
c'est une menace majeure pour nos
classes moyennes qui sera les premières
victimes d'une cure massive d'austérité
et d'augmentation brutale d'impôts aussi
grâce à l'activité au travail grâce à la
maîtrise des dépenses grâce à des
réformes structurelles nous allons tenir
notre cap qui doit nous conduire à
repasser sous les 3 % de déficit d'ici
2027 nous le ferons sans augmenter les
impôts nous le ferons en menant une
revue de dépenses ambitieuse qui
concernera tous les ministères des
premières mesures d'économie seront
annoncées fin mars et nous y
travaillerons ensemble en vue du PLF je
souhaite que la représentation nationale
dans son ensemble puisse se saisir très
en amont du PLF de ces propositions
d'économie et que nous puissions
travailler échanger ensemble avant la
discussion du PLF nous atteindrons aussi
nos objectifs en renforçant encore notre
lutte contre la fraude qu'elle soit
fiscale sociale ou douanière vous savez
combien j'y suis attentif je regarde la
sénatrice Goulet mais beaucoup coup
d'entre vous sont très mobilisés sur
cette question Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs grâce à ces
réformes grâce à l'activité au travail
nous allons pouvoir continuer à réarmer
nos services publics faire en sorte que
tous les Français en soi fier je pense à
notre système de santé nous devons aller
plus vite et plus fort nous le devons à
nos soignants c'est grâce à leur
engagement sans faille que le système
tient et je veux leur rendre hommage
alors je ne me paye pas de mot je sais
que les soignants comme comme les
patients attendent des actes et avec le
gouvernement nous allons continuer à
agir nous devons d'abord faire en sorte
qu'il y ait plus de médecins et plus de
soignants dans notre pays c'est le sens
de la suppression du numérus closus
mesure structurant mais dont les effets
d'abord ne se feront pas sentir
immédiatement et qui doit probablement
être renforcé pour que nous puissions
former encore davantage de médecins je
ne me résoudrai jamais à ce que des
jeunes Français qui veulent devenir
médecins qui travaillent pour devenir
médecins doivent par à l'étranger à
l'est de l'Europe ou ailleurs pour faire
leurs études de
médecine pour agir rapidement évidemment
parce que nous avons aussi besoin de
médecins tout de suite et que cela prend
un certain temps de former des médecins
nous allons régulariser les médecins
étrangers sur notre territoire c'est un
engagement du Président de la République
nous allons aussi permettre au soignants
qui exercent des années d'avoir des
passerelles effectives et efficace pour
les études de médecine j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire hier à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est une proposition qui
émane d'ailleurs du député nuder du
groupe LR à l'Assemblée nationale une
infirmière anesthésiste qui a un bac + 5
qui a plusieurs années d'expérience elle
doit pouvoir rentrer au moins en 3e
année de médecine si elle le souhaite
pour devenir médecin et exercer dans les
années à venir dans notre
pays pour agir rapidement nous allons
aussi libérer davantage de temps médical
nous doublerons le nombre d'assistants
médicaux nous allons assumer de dire que
quand on a un rendez-vous chez le
médecin qu'on ne s'y présente pas sans
prévenir quel que soit son statut quel
que soit sa couverture on paye sa
consultation c'est une question d'accès
aux soins chaque année ce sont des
millions de consultations qui ne peuvent
pas être assuré parce qu'elles avaient
été prévues et que les patients ne se
sont pas présentés les médecins nous le
disent les Français qui n'ont pas accès
à des consultations suffisamment t nous
le disent il faut responsabiliser de ce
point de vue là assumer que les droits
et devoirs c'est pour tout le
monde je m'y engage également nous
allons continuer à lutter contre les
déserts médicaux c'est une angoisse de
nos concitoyens notamment dans la
ruralité dans les petites villes ou dans
les villes moyennes c'est une
préoccupation forte du Sénat je le sais
et je sais combien vous vous en faites
le relais c'est une priorité d'action de
mon gouvernement depuis 2017 nous avons
déployé le service d'accès aux soins le
sas qui permet d'améliorer l'accès à la
santé j'étais à Dijon il y a encore
quelques jours avec certains d'entre
vous nous avons vu à quel point ce
système fonctionne et permet de mieux
orienter des patients sur du non
programmé et donc de de de désengorger
les urgences et de permettre à des
patients d'être pris en charge en ville
quand c'est ce qui est nécessaire d'ici
à l'été je souhaite que chaque
département soit doté d'un service
d'accès aux soins et si ce n'est pas le
cas si les réponses sont toujours
insuffisantes je n'ai pas de tabou et
des obligations de garde pour les
médecins libéraux pourrai être décidé
enfin je veux avoir un mot de la santé
de nos jeunes du travail exceptionnel
mené par les infirmières scolaires pour
détecter conseiller soigner nous avons
besoin de plus d'infirmières scolaires
nous voulons rendre leur métier plus
attractif aussi nous leur verserons une
prime exceptionnelle de 800 € au mois de
mai et à partir de cette date toutes les
infirmières scolaires de France à partir
du mois de mai seront payé 200 € nets de
plus par mois en moyenne c'est juste et
c'est nécessaire nous avancerons aussi
pour déployer des maisons des
adolescents dans tous les territoires
pour revaloriser également et revoir
complètement le dispositif mon soutien
PSI pour que des jeunes des jeunes qui
sont en dépression des jeunes qui ont un
malêtre des jeunes qui ont des pensées
suicidaires puissent accéder à une prise
en charge par un psychologue beaucoup
plus rapidement je sais que le Sénat là
aussi s'était engagé je regarde la
sénatrice de lâre qui avait beaucoup
travaillé sur ce sujet mais vous n vous
n'êtes pas la seule et d'autres en
avaient
parlé je parle des sénateurs mais tous
les sénateurs s'engagent j'aurais pu
citer sur la santé la sénatrice
chilinger et d'autres ici se sont
engagés le réarmement de nos services
publics c'est le réarmement de notre
école aujourd'hui les parents
s'inquiètent du niveau scolaire et les
enseignants ont le sentiment de ne plus
avoir les moyen de faire progresser
leurs élèves la réponse ça doit d'abord
être le choc des savoirs c'est faire en
sorte que l'école ne soit pas un
escalator qui permettrait de passer de
classe en classe automatiquement sans
avoir à faire d'efforts sans que
personne ne regarde si on a le niveau
suffisant pour réussir dans la classe
supérieure c'est pourquoi nous
assumerons et le texte sera pris dans
les toutes prochaines semaines de
redonner le dernier mot sur la décision
du redoublement à l'équipe pédagogique
et non plus à la famille il n'y a
personne de mieux qu'un enseignant pour
savoir le niveau d'un élève et sa
capacité à réussir dans la classe
supérieur nous assumerons également de
relever le niveau du brevet des collèges
nous avons dit et nous ne tiendrons que
dès cette année nous supprimerons le
correctif académique qui conduisait
depuis des années à gonfler
artificiellement les notes de nos élèves
au brevet dans beaucoup de territoires
pour atteindre un certain niveau un
certain taux de réussite pour faire
plaisir à tout le monde
mentir à nos élèves sur leurs notes
mentir aux familles sur le niveau de
leurs enfants c'est ne pas répondre à
l'objectif et à la nécessité de
l'exigence que nous avons pour nos
élèves et à la fin c'est ne pas
respecter notre objectif d'égalité des
chances un diplôme sans conséquence
c'est un diplôme qui n'a pas de sens n
nous réhausserons le niveau du brevet
pour apprendre chacun doit pouvoir aller
à son rythme c'est le sens des groupes
de niveau qui se mettront en place au
collège dès la rentrée prochaine en
français et en mathématiques un
enseignant en français qui a dans sa
classe des élèves qui ne savent pas lire
avec des élèves qui savent très bien
lire il n'arrivve plus à faire
progresser personne nous assumerons ces
groupes de niveau en français et en
mathématique pour apprendre les élèves
ne doivent pas être distraits et
obnubilés par les écrans les écrans sont
une catastrophe éducative et sanitaire
en puissance alors nous avons banni les
téléphones portables au collège et
conformément à l'engagement du président
de la République nous nous déploierons
de nouvelles mesures pour mieux réguler
l'usage des écrans à l'école et en
dehors de l'école j'ajoute que pour
apprendre nos élèves doient avoir des
enseignants devant eux nous avons déjà
multiplié par 3 la part d'ord remplacé
mais nous n'y sommes pas encore nous
évaluerons les effets du PACT
enseignants et nous en tirerons toutes
les leçons pour réarmer notre école nos
élèves ont besoin d'être heureux c'est
pour leur bien-être que nous luttons
pied à pied sans relâche contre le
harcèlement scolaire je sais que c'est
un sujet pour lequel là aussi beaucoup
ou se sont engagés sur ces bancs c'est
un défi qui me tient à cœur je suis fier
d'avoir lancé une nouvelle stratégie
contre le harcèlement fier que ce soit
désormais à l'élève harceleur de quitter
l'établissement et non plus à l'élève
harcelés c'est pour le bien-être de tous
les élèves que nous bâtissons une
société inclusive pour une école
inclusive pour nos enfants en situation
de handicap l'état prendra désormais en
charge le salaire des AES sur la pause
de midi c'était une proposition de loi
portée par le sénateur Vial et nous la
soutiendrons nous mettons fin ainsi à
des années de querell entre les
collectivités locales et l'État au
détriment des élèves en situation de
handicap et de ceux qui les aident si je
parle des élèves de nos écoles je veux
aussi avoir un mot pour les étudiantes
et les étudiants de notre pays nous
continuerons à agir pour eux pour notre
enseignement supérieur à le tourner vers
des filières d'avenir pourvoyeuses de
sens et d'emploi nous continuerons à
agir pour celles et ceux qui pour qui
étudi demandent des sacrifices et qui
sont les plus en difficulté alors nous
avons maintenu le repas à 1 € cru pour
les étudiants boursiers et pour les
étudiants non boursiers qui en auraient
besoin et nous menons une réforme des
bourses qui a déjà permis de toucher
plus d'étudiants et revaloriser les
bourses jusqu'à 127 € supplémentaires
par mois dans l'Hexagone et jusqu'à 157
€ supplémentaires par mois pour les
étudiants dans les outres-mèes Mesdames
et Messieurs les sénatrices sénateur le
réarmement de l'école sera vain si nos
valeurs ne sont pas respectées si
l'autorité n'y est pas respectée comme
ministre j'ai toujours été du côté de
nos professeurs comme chef du
gouvernement je le reste et je le
resterai l'autorité c'est respecter les
professeurs et nos valeurs républicaines
la relation entre un professeur et son
élève n'est pas une relation d'égal à
égal il y a celui qui sait il y a celui
qui apprend celui qui sait à l'autorité
sur celui qui qui apprend parce que
celui qui sait à l'autorité du savoir
qui lui est conféré par sa mission et
par ses années de
formation l'autorité c'est donc
respecter les professeurs et nos valeurs
républicaines c'est pouvoir enseigner
tout le programme sans exception et
avoir une échelle de sanction adaptée
pour les élèves qui ne l'accepteraient
pas c'est veiller à ce que tous les
élèves respectent nos valeurs
républicaines la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité et au sein d'elle évidemment
la laïcité fondement même de l'école de
la République pour que nous devons
continuer à défendre comme nous l'avons
fait en assumant d'interdire la BAA dans
tous les établissements scolaires de
notre
pays c'est aussi l'autorité et
l'autorité des valeurs de la République
apprendre partout les paroles de la
Marseillaise doubler le nombre d'heures
d'instruction civique dès le collège
l'autorité c'est à l'école c'est aussi
dans la famille lors des émeutes de
juillet la France a été frappé par le
choc elle a aussi été sidérée par la
jeunesse des éémetiers des jeunes de
moins de 15 ans parfois de moins de 13
ans des jeunes qui n'ont plus de repèr
pour qui la violence est parfois devenue
un pass-temp ces jeunes nous devons
pouvoir les accompagner nous devons
aussi pouvoir mieux les sanctionner avec
des peines adaptées aujourd'hui il est
impossible de prononcer une peine de
travaux d'intérêt général en dessous de
16 ans alors nous créerons les travaux
d'intérêt éduc
qui pourront être prononc y compris pour
les jeunes de moins de 16 ans nous
viendrons en appui des familles qui n'y
arrivent plus de ces Mr parfois seul qui
doivent élever plusieurs enfants et sont
parfois impuissantes face à la dérive et
au mauvaises fréquentation de certains
nous proposerons sur simple demande des
parents que les jeunes à la dérive
puissent être placés en internat nous
avons aujourd'hui 500 places d'internat
qui sont vacantes dans notre pays ces
places doivent servir à accueillir des
jeunes qui en ont besoin
enfin nous devons aussi responsabiliser
les parents des jeunes délinquants qui
se seraient volontairement soustrait à
leur responsabilité parentale il
pourrait désormais être condamné à des
travaux d'intérêt général là aussi nous
avancerons l'autorité s'est également
dans la rue la délinquence mine la
confiance dans le pacte républicain
beaucoup a été fait grâce à des moyens
inédits mais nous devons aussi revoir
notre stratégie nous devons veiller à la
sécurité de tous partout sur le
territoire y compris dans notre rue ité
c'est pourquoi nous installerons 238
nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie nous
allons amplifier encore la lutte contre
la drogue qui est la matrice de tous les
vices nous continuerons notre stratégie
de pilonnage des points de deal qui
montre de premiers résultat avec déjà
un/art des points de deal qui ont été
supprimé nous lancerons un nouveau plan
de lutte contre les stupéfiants avec
notamment une mesure forte taper les
trafiquants au porte-monnaie en gelant
leurs avoirs nous voulons également agir
contre la délinquence du quotidien nous
aurons une attention part particulière à
la lutte contre les cambriolages enfin
pour être efficace nous avons besoin
d'une réponse pénale à la hauteur nous
voulons une justice plus rapide et plus
efficace nous lui en donnons les moyens
vous le savez avec une augmentation
historique de son budget mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs alors que
j'évoque le défi des services publics je
pense bien entendu à nos territoires
d'outremè les outr-emèes sont une chance
immense pour la France ce sont aussi des
terres où tous les défis semblent se
concentrer le défi de la vie chè auquel
nous devons répondre le défi de l'emploi
alors que le chômage est plus élevé que
dans l'Hexagone le défi de la santé de
l'école de la sécurité de la lutte
contre l'immigration illégale de la
transition écologique alors nous allons
continuer à agir pour nos outr-mères
continuer à prendre des mesures
concrètes pour améliorer le quotidien de
nos concitoyens ultramarins nous devrons
notamment répondre aux singularités et
au défis de Mayotte avec un projet de
loi spécifique sur le territoire enfin
il existe un lien particulier entre
l'hôtel de Matignon et la
Nouvelle-Calédonie un lien comme un écho
au dialogue à l'espoir de paix et de
construction de l'avenir par TR par
trois fois la Nouvelle-Calédonie a
choisi la République il faut maintenant
que les échanges en cours et le
processus politique aboutisse j'y serai
attentif et vous examinerez dans
quelques semaines un projet de loi
constitutionnelle sur l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs le
trisème combat de mon gouvernement c'est
la transition écologique ces derniers
mois nous nous sommes dotés d'un plan
unique au monde la planification écolog
grâce à elle nous avons une feuille de
route précise secteur par secteur pour
baisser nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de 55 % d'ici 2030 pour nous
adapter au changement inévitables pour
le climat pour restaurer notre
biodiversité et préserver nos ressources
ces objectifs nous y tenons nous les
atteindrons le préalable c'est de faire
bloc de ne pas mener la transition
écologique seulement avec les uns et
contre les autres nous voulons faire la
transition avec le peuple et avec les
élus sans brutalité sans invective sans
décroissance nous ne voulons pas montrer
du doigt pointer du doigt mais au
contraire rassembler toutes celles et
tous ceux qui ont conscience de la
nécessité d'agir nous serons toujours
les porteurs d'une écologie des
solutions qui offre des alternatives et
des réponses à ceux qui ont peur de la
transition écologique je ne prendrai
qu'un exemple les transports mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs vous savez mieux
que personne combien il est impossible
de priver nos concitoyens de leurs
voiture dans la ruralité dans les
petites villes dans les villes moyennes
les privés de voitures ce seraiit les PR
de travail les privés de loisirs les
privés de vie sociale alors plutôt que
les privations nous proposons des
solutions c'est le sens de l'offre de
location de véhicules électriques pour
moins de 100 € par mois cette offre est
lancée et elle est un succès c'est aussi
la raison pour laquelle nous proposons
de renforcer de soutenir les
alternatives là où c'est possible ça
n'est pas possible partout c'est ce que
je disais il y a un instant et vous le
savez sur les transports en commun
notamment au niveau métropolitain et
régional nous allons continuer à agir
les engagements du Président de la
République sur le ferroviaire seront
tenus la clé de réussite de notre
transition écologique c'est sa capacité
à s'encréer dans les territoires les
territoires ne nous ont pas attendu pour
agir les concertations se sont
intensifiées depuis quelques mois avec
le lancement des cops territoriales qui
rassemblent les élus locaux à tous les
échelons territoire par territoire c'est
ensemble avec les élus que nous pourrons
mener les meilleurs diagnostics sur les
enjeux de chaque territoire c'est
ensemble avec élus que nous pourrons
bâtir les solutions les plus adaptées
c'est ensemble que nous pourrons
disposer des financements adaptés l'État
sera au rendez-vous et je souhaite que
les plans locaux de financement de la
transition écologique soient tous
conclus pour cet été enfin c'est
ensemble que nous pourrons bâtir la
résilience des territoire face au
dérèglements climatiques en prononçant
ces mots je pense notamment aux victimes
des inondations dans le Pas de Calais
c'est auprès d'eux que j'ai fait mon
premier déplacement en tant que Premier
ministre comme je m'y étais engagé j'y
retournerai très prochainement auprès
des victimes des inondations pour faire
un point sur la reconstruction sur le
déblocage des aides d'urgence mais aussi
pour préparer l'avenir la transition
écologique c'est aussi réussir la
transition énergétique là encore je sais
que ce sujet importe particulièrement au
Sénat notre stratégie repose sur trois
piliers la sobriété le nucléaire et le
renouvelable c'est grâce à cet équilibre
que nous pouvons conquérir notre
indépendance énergétique garantir des
prix bas et une énergie décarbonée aux
Français je veux le dire ici clairement
comme je l'ai fait hier à l'Assemblée
nationale nous assumons pleinement le
choix du nucléaire nous le soutenons
nous développons de nouveau programme et
2024 sera une grande année pour le
nucléaire français avec la mise en
service de le Pr de
flamandville enfin pour mener le combat
de l'écologie à la française nous devons
aussi
poursuivre nous devons aussi poursuivre
notre réarmement agricole protéger notre
exception agricole française c'est mon
engagement
c'est le combat du gouvernement depuis
2017 avec les plans de filière avec les
lois égalimes avec l'assurance récolte
avec le varen de l'eau ce sont les
positions de la France au niveau
européen pour protéger nos agriculteurs
et se battre pour des me pour des
meilleures mesures et pour des closuses
miroires aider nos agriculteurs à
produire plus en les libérant des
démarches administratives qui les
éloignent de leurs bêtes et de leurs
champs les aider à produire plus car
c'est la clé de notre indépendance
alimentaire nous devons aussi continuer
à les protéger que ce soit contre les
crises et nous le faisons
systématiquement depuis 7 ans ou bien
contre la concurrence desloyales de ceux
qui n'ont pas les mêmes standards que
nous et dont les produits arrivent
pourtant en France les crises de ces
dernières semaines mouvement si plutôt
des dernières semaines vient de très
loin la situation ne peut se régler tout
de suite ce serait un mensonge que de le
dire ce qui est vrai en revanche c'est
que nous sommes déterminés à changer les
choses avec nos agriculteurs dès la
semaine dernière j'ai annoncé de
premières réponses pour une juste
rémunération des agriculteurs avec un
renforcement des contrôles dans le cadre
des négociations commerciales pour la
simplification avec 10 normes très
concrètes qui seront simplifiées dans
les T prochains jours et j'ajoute que
partout en France j'ai demandé au préfet
de réunir les représentants des
agriculteurs dans chaque département le
premier département qui a commencé ce
travail c'est la HauteGaronne en
quelques réunions sur une semaine quatre
arrêtés préfectoraux ont été abrogés
dans le département de HauteGaronne ça
montre que cette mesure fonctionne et
que cette méthode fonctionne j'ai
demandé qu'elle soit dès cette semaine
dupliquée sur l'ensemble du territoire
des réponses rapides pour la trésorerie
des exploitants avec l'annulation de la
hausse de la taxe sur le GNR agricole
avec l'engagement que les aides de la
PAC arrivent avant le 15 mars des
réponses rapides face aux crises enfin
avec l'ouverture lundi prochain du
guichet de prise en charge du fond
vétérinaire pour la MHE ou encore avec
le doublement du fond d'urgence pour la
Bretagne évidemment il reste à faire
avec mon gouvern ement nous sommes
pleinement
mobilisés nous avons avancé encore ces
derniers jours avec les agriculteurs
avec leurs représentants avanthier soir
hier soir ce matin encore avec j'étais
avec les représentants des agriculteurs
nous allons continuer à le faire
notamment à le faire pour faciliter et
favoriser l'installation et la
transmission des exploitations pour un
meilleur renouvellement des générations
je ne crois pas à la crise des vocations
en agriculture il y a beaucoup de jeunes
qui veulent s'engager en agriculture et
des moins jeunes d'ailleurs qui parfois
veulent aussi se reconvertir et
s'engager pour l'agriculture c'est une
crise de l'attractivité il faut lever
tous les freins qui font que ces
vocations sont parfois bridées nous
avancerons sur ce terrain il faut
continuer à avancer sur la question du
revenu et notamment sur l'application
des lois égalim je rappelle quand même
qu'avant la loi égalim c'était la loi
LME de 2009 qui s'appliquait qui donnait
les pleins pouvoirs à la grande
distribution et que la loi égalime a
constitué à ce titre un progrès je n'ai
rencontré aucun agriculteur à ce stade
qui m'a demandé de revenir à la
situation prè égalim au contraire il
nous demande qu'égalim soit mieux
appliqué et que sur un certain nombre de
points elle elle soit corrigé c'est
l'objet de nos travaux et de nos
discussions en ce moment nous
continuerons à avancer sur la
simplification avec de nouvelles mesures
pour simplifier le quotidien très
concrètement nous continuerons à avancer
sur la relation entre les agriculteurs
et un certain nombre de services de
l'État notamment l'ofb j'ai annoncé de
première mesure vendredi nous allons
continuer à le faire nous allons
continuer à avancer avec eux sur la
concurrence équitable en renforçant les
contrôles sur les produits les choses
sont simples un produit qui rentre en
France doit avoir les mêmes standards de
qualité qu'un produit cultivé en France
sinon ça s'appelle de la concurrence
déloyales et nous sommes déterminés à la
combattre et je rappelle je rappelle que
c'est cette majorité notre majorité et
d'ailleurs je crois que la majorité
sénatorialea
qui a qui a assumé de réautoriser
l'utilisation des ncotinoïdes pour la
production de la betterave après
l'annulation qui était intervenu sous le
quinquen de François Hollande une une
interdiction sans aucune solution si
nous n'avions pas pris cette décision il
n'y aura plus de filiier betrave nous
avons assumé de le faire et nous avons
assumé de tenir le pas d'interdiction
sans solution depuis 2017 enfin nous
agissons au niveau européen nous nous
sommes fixés trois priorités les
importations ukrainiennes les
négociations mercosour et les jachers
trois priorités immédiates le président
de la République s'est mobilisé sur
chacun de ces sujets dès ce matin un
paquet de mesures a été adopté par la
commission qu'il s'agisse de la
dérogation sur les sur les jachè et je
rappelle que ça fait des mois que la
France est mobilisé nous avons réuni
autour de nous une coalition de 22 États
qui nous permettent aujourd'hui
d'obtenir cette mesure il s'agit de la
mise en place de mécanismes de
sauvegarde sur les importations
ukrainiennes notamment sur les volailles
les œufs et le sucre les choses avanent
des annonces ont été faites ce matin
parce que nous nous battons enfin
s'agissant du mercosour la position de
la France est claire le compte n'y est
pas et les conditions ne sont pas
réunies pour sa conclusion nous avons
bloqué sa conclusion j'ajoute que
j'aurais un principe clair appliquer le
droit européen mais rien de plus je
prendrai des mesures pour éviter toute
surtransposition ce n'est évidemment pas
tout et je le dis je l'ai dit à
inststant nous allons aller plus loin
j'étais encore ce les représentant des
agriculteurs des contacts sont encore
prévus dans les prochaines heures je
sais que vous l'êtes aussi Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs et
j'aurai très prochainement dans les tous
prochains jours à faire des annonces à
la suite de ce travail que nous menons
ensemble monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
je vous parle de souveraineté je veux
aussi dire que je verraai au
souveraineté au respect de notre
souveraineté nationale une souveraineté
nationale portée par des armées
remarquables dont nous aurons doublé le
budget en de Kena ce sont des moyens
sans précédent comme le prévoit la loi
de programmation militaire nous
respecterons nos engagements et je tiens
ici avec vous à rendre hommage à tous
nos militaires qui défendent et
protègent la France et nos
valeurs je veux aussi m'incliner avec
respect devant la mémoire de ceux qui
sont tombés en servant notre pays notre
souveraineté nationale c'est aussi le
respect de nos frontières hier j'ai posé
un principe simple accueillir moins pour
accueillir mieux je m'y tiens grâce à la
loi immigration nous avons renforcé
notre droit grâce au pacte asile
immigration décidé au niveau européen
nous sommes enfin en capacité de décider
qui entre dans Schengen ou non et grâce
à la réforme à venir de l'aide médicale
d'État comme s'y est engagé ma
prédécesseur sur la base des
recommandations du rapport evvin
stéphanini nous serons rapidement en
mesure d'avancer là aussi enfin notre
souveraineté nationale c'est encore
notre notre souveraineté européenne nous
entrons dans une année cruciale pour
l'Europe une année où il faudra dire
stop ou encore une année où il faudra
choisir entre la faiblesse de
l'isolement et la force du collectif
depuis 2017 l'Europe s'est prise en main
elle est devenue plus forte plus
politique elle apporte des améliorations
concrètes dans la vie de nos concitoyens
je pense au vaccin contre le covid au
moyens pour le plan de relance au
soutien à notre industrie elle nous
permet également d'aborder certains
grands défis avec plus de force et de
puissance je pense à la lutte cont ô des
règlements climatiques ou encore aux
avancées que nous avons obtenu face au
géants du numérique ou aux
multinationales qui font de
l'optimisation fiscale monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs assumer notre souveraineté
c'est aussi défendre résolument nos
valeurs et chercher toujours de nouveaux
progrès nos valeurs c'est notre
exception culturelle notre patrimoine
est le symbole de notre histoire nous
devons le préserver et le mettre
toujours en avant notre création fait
notre rayonnement et notre fierté nous
devons la soutenir nous devons la rendre
plus accessible à tous notamment dans la
ruralité et de premières initiatives ont
été lancées par le gouvernement ces
derniers jours nos valeurs c'est
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
c'est le sens du futur congé de
naissance mieux rémunéré et que les
parents pourront se répartir alors que
le congé parental lui éloignait
durablement les femmes de l'emploi nos
valeurs s'est affirmé le droit des
femmes à disposer de leur corps hier
dans un vote qui a dépassé l'écvage
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté un projet
de loi constitutionnel pour inscrire la
liberté de recourir à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans la
Constitution alors que les droits des
femmes sont toujours les premiers remis
en cause je suis intimement convaincu
qu'inscrire cette liberté dans la
Constitution est une protection
nécessaire vous avez déjà réussi à
travailler ensemble assemblée national
et Sénat autour d'une rédaction commune
je suis sû que vous y parviendrez à
nouveau enfin nos valeurs c'est
permettre à chacun de mourir dans la
dignité la fin de vie relève de l'intime
c'est une question qui renvoie à sa
propre histoire à ses propres
convictions à ce que l'on a vécu à ce
que l'on a vu aujourd'hui le constat de
beaucoup de malades de beaucoup de
familles de beaucoup de Français et
pressant devons entendre leur appel à y
répondre avec vous avec gravité prudence
et dans le respect des conviction de
chacune et de chacun nous le ferons
d'une part nous déploierons davantage
d'unités de soins palliatifs il en faut
une par département au moins ensuite
nous examinerons avant l'été un projet
de loi sur l'aide active à mourir
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs pour chacune de
nos politiques publiques sans exception
nous agirons main dans la main avec les
élus locaux à l'écoute de leurs
préoccupations de leurs alertes et de
leurs attentes élu local c'est un mandat
que je connais à mon niveau je ne suis
qu'un conseiller municipal d'opposition
dans sa commune depuis près d' une
dizaine d'années déjà une dizaine
d'années mais je sais à quel point je le
vois dans ma ville de vre je le vois à
chaque fois que je me déplace je sais à
quel point leur engagement est absolu
ETL local c'est le plus beau des
engagements c'est se battre pour des
projets les bâtir et les voir grandir
c'est se battre pour ses concitoyens et
prendre des décisions concrètes qui
changent réellement le quotidien c'est
se battre pour un territoire une
parcelle de notre pays qui détient une
part de son histoire et de son identité
être élu local c'est répondre à nos
concitoyens tous les jours sans
exception c'est agir pour eux croire en
eux être prêt à déplacer les montagnes
pour eux tous les jours sans exception
avec vous je veux rendre hommage à tous
les élus locaux de France les remercier
leur dire ma gratitude ma confiance
celle de mon gouvernement leur dire ma
détermination aussi est celle de mon
gouvernement à construire l'avenir avec
eux à leur faciliter la vie leur mandat
et leur mission nous sommes prêts à
avancer ensemble prêt à accélérer avec
les territoires qui le souhaitent sur
les sujets qu'il désire prêt à
expérimenter à différencier à adapter
nos règles mais pour réussir il faut que
les choses soient claires je sais que
les élus locaux et vous avec demandent
des
clarifications sur les compétences sur
le statut des élus sur le financement
des
collectivités reconnaissons-le les
compétences des uns et des autres sont
dans un véritable cetê elle s'enchevêtre
c'est inefficace dans notre action
publique c'est dangereux
démocratiquement car beaucoup de nos
concitoyens ne savent plus vers qui se
tourner ne savent plus qui est
responsable de quoi et sont souvent
perdus déçu et sans réponse c'est le
cocktail parfait pour nourrir la
défiance et la colère autant dire le
cocktail parfait pour faire le lit des
populistes alors là aussi la France a
besoin d'une clarification et d'une
simplification forte c'est tout l'enjeu
de la mission confié au député Eric WT
par le Président de la République sur la
clarification des compétences des
collectivités Eric WT évidemment dans
son travail j'ai échangé avec lui sur
l'état d'avancement de sa mission a
beaucoup consulté vous avez était un
certain nombre évidemment à le
rencontrer à le voir évidemment il
s'appuie aussi sur un certain nombre de
travaux qui avaient été conduit
notamment ici au Sénat beaucoup de
missions de rapports j'en suis convaincu
ont été commis ont été proposé l'enjeu
désormais c'est d'avancer et d'avancer
vite vers cette Clif vers cette
clarification des compétences Eric vert
nous rendra ses premières conclusions
d'ici au printemps notre objectif est
simple
dépasser les débats stériles sur
l'échelon à conserver ou supprimer et
nous concentrer sur les moyens
d'améliorer vraiment l'action publique
locale la règle doit être simple pour
une compétence il faut un responsable et
un financement dédié et je souhaite
qu'une loi construite avec les
associations d'élus soit présentée avant
la fin de l'année 2024 pour tirer les
conclusions de la mission d'Eric vert et
des travaux qui ont été conduits dans
cette chambre et à l'Assemblée nationale
dès maintenant l'État prend sa part dans
cet effort de simplification d'une part
nous simplifierons drastiquement les
normes applicables aux collectivités
pour redonner du pouvoir d'agir aux élus
locaux cela passera notamment par une
réforme du droit de dérogation nous
voulons casser les carcans qui brident
les initiatives des élus locaux d'autre
part je veux réaffirmer un principe
simple le préfet doit avoir autorité sur
les opérateurs de son département pour
mieux coordonner leur
action
sur tous ces sujets je souhaite de
premiers résultats et des décisions
fortes dans les 6 mois j'y veillerai en
lien étroit avec les préfets permettre
aux élus d'accomplir pleinement leur
mission c'est aussi leur donner les
marges de manœuvre dont ils ont besoin
nous avons beaucoup fait notamment d'un
point de vue financier je le rappelle
nous avons tenu nos engagements
vis-à-vis des collectivités dans les de
deux derniers PLF pour la première fois
depuis 13 ans la DGF a augmenté ça
n'était pas arrivé depuis 13 ans ça
n'était pas arrivé depuis 13 ans il y a
13 ans elle
baissait nous nous avons assumer de
porter des dispositifs pour soutenir les
collectivités les plus fragilisées par
l'inflation et notamment la hausse des
prix de
l'énergie cette hausse de la DGF n'est
pas une hausse en trompeleuil qui n
concernerait que quelques uns l'année
dernière pour la quasi totalité des
communes la DGF est resté stable ou
augmenté je le rappelle il n'y a pas si
longtemps que cela avec une autre
majorité elle avait baissé et beaucoup
baissé nous devons maintenant aller plus
loin c'est pourquoi je vous l'annonce je
souhaite que les préfets aient désormais
une vision pluriannuelle jusqu'en 2027
des dotations d'investissement pour
mieux accompagner les collectivités et
leur donner de la visibilité dans leur
projet c'est pourquoi mon gouvernement
veillera toujours à ce que la lutte
nécessaire contre le dérèglement
climatique ne soit pas un frein au
développement des territoires je pense
notamment à la question duusan et je
salue tout le travail que vous avez mené
ici l'année dernière pour l'assouplir
permettre aux élus d'accomplir
pleinement leur mission c'est aussi les
protéger partout les élus sont
confrontés à des situations difficiles
tendues et partout ils répondent présent
tous me parlent de leur passion pour
leur mandat mais beaucoup abordent aussi
leur découragement face à l'explosion
des incivilités des menaces et des
attaques nos élus sont en première ligne
face à une société qui se brutalise ils
en sont les premières victimes insultes
menace de mort frein d'une voiture
coupée domicile vandalisé menace
homophobe et parfois même famille
attaqué je le dis clairirement qui
attaque un élu attaque la République
attaque notre modèle démocratique
attaque les fondements mêmes de notre
société toujours la République devra la
protection à ses élus et avec le
président de la République et l'ensemble
de mon gouvernement nous serons toujours
à leur côté nous allons par exemple
renforcer notre droit et alourdir les
peines prévues contre ceux qui attaquent
nos élus je sais que des textes des lois
avaient été pris encore récemment sur ce
sujet-là et la réalité c'est que le
sujet fondamental c'est évidemment que
la réponse pénale soit au rendez-vous
nous avons d'ors et déjà pris des
mesures pour la renforcer mais c'est
dans le cœur et les racines de la
société qu'il faut agir évidemment qu'il
faut punir et sanctionner celui qui s'en
prend un élu celui qui s'en prend ur
celui qui s'en prend un policier celui
qui s'en prend à celles et ceux qui
incarnent notre République mais en
cherchant à les à leur répondre et à les
sanctionner n'oublions jamais que la
priorité ça doit être de s'interroger
sur ce qui fait dans notre société qu'on
en arrive à avoir des personnes qui se
permettent de s'en prendre à ce point à
la République et là l'école je le dis
aussi elle a un rôle absolument
fondamental et tout ce que nous allons
faire sur le renforcement de
l'instruction civique sur la revue de
l'échelle des sanctions dans l'école sur
la capacité à prendre des sanctions
beaucoup plus jeunes sur des mineurs des
sanctions qui soient adaptées plutôt que
d'attendre qu'un jeune avance son âge
fasse commettre des infractions plus
graves pour le sanctionner lourdement
revenons-en au bon vieux principe de
sanction immédiate très tôt proportionné
mais qui permettent oui j'assume de le
dire même si ça n'est pas la mission
fondamentale de l'école d'éduquer des
jeunes et de leur faire comprendre ce
qu'est la
[Applaudissements]
République
quand ces violences s'ajoutent aux
lourdeur du mandat à l'addition des
normes qui contraignent de plus en plus
l'action des élus parfois
malheureusement certains baissent les
bras alors nous devons faire plus et
faire mieux pour les soutenir dans leur
engagement je veux mettre en place un
véritable statut de l'élu local
permettant aux élus d'être mieux
protégés mieux indemnisés mieux
valorisés je m'appuierai pour cela là
aussi sur des travaux parlementaire je
pense au travaux de la sénatrice
Françoise
Gattel
[Applaudissements]
mais aussi à ce mais aussi à ceux des
députés violette spilbout et Sébastien
Jumel qui ont également travaillé sur le
sujet vous pouvez aussi les applaudir il
s'engage pour les
élus faciliter l'engagement faciliter
les conditions d'exercice des mandat
faciliter les reconversions après laave
d'élu sur tous ces sujets nous pouvons
avancer ensemble unis et trouver des
accords au-delà des clivages partisans
protéger nos élus n'attend pas je
souhaite que nous avancions vite et que
des propositions puissent aboutir d'ici
la fin du premier trimestre enfin je
souhaite améliorer toujours notre vie et
notre démocratie locale aussi comme l'a
annoncé le président de la République
nous réformerons le mode de scrutin à
Paris Lyon et Marseille nous adopterons
un principe simple un habitant une voix
chaque électeur doit pouvoir et lire son
maire beaucoup plus directement un texte
sera présenté d'ici la fin de
l'année nous continuerons le déploiement
du plan France ruralité qui va permettre
le retour de nos services publics dans
les territoires nous allons aider les
élus pour revitaliser les centrville les
centrebourgs comme nous avons commencé à
le faire avec les plans action cœur de
ville nous continuerons à accompagner
les territoires ruraux la dotation
d'aménité rurale a été doublée cette
année nous pour poursuivront cet
engagement dans les années à venir
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs cette feuille de route a été
construite pour répondre aux
préoccupations de tous les élus à leur
contact et à leur écoute mais elle ne
marchera pas si on la met en œuvre
depuis Paris je continuerai à aller sur
le terrain sans relâche pour échanger
avec nos élus locaux car parler aux élus
locaux c'est toujours prendre le pou du
pays je continuerai à agir en lien
étroit avec les associations d'élus dans
le respect et l'écoute elles sont
déterminantes pour trouver des solutions
je continuerai bien sûr à agir avec le
Sénat car vous faites entendre la voix
des
territoires Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs je viens de vous
faire part du Cap que suivra mon
gouvernement mon ambition autour du
projet du président de la République
vous la connaissez bâtir notre
souveraineté restaurer la fierté
française avoir pleinement le contrôle
de nos vies et notre destin en main
cette ambition je la porterai avec
toutes les femmes et les hommes de bonne
volonté prêts à agir pour notre pays
avec nous je la porterai avec nos élus
locaux engagés pour leur territoire et
déterminés à les défendre je la porterai
avec les Français en les écoutant
toujours en parlant toujours franchement
en agissant toujours résolument je
lapporterai à l'Europe dans une Europe
résolue à construire une puissance
européenne capable de répondre aux
crises et d'agir au plus près de nos
concitoyens cet après-midi dans ce Sénat
Grand Conseil des communes de France de
gambeta dans ce Sénat profondément
républicain profondément attaché à nos
territoires et entièrement tourner vers
l'avenir j'ai confiance j'ai confiance
car je sais que nous avons l'amour de la
France en commun et l'envie d'agir en
partage j'ai confiance car on sa ici
dépasser les clivages pour agir ensemble
au service des Français et de l'intérêt
général de grands défis nous attend
ensemble je vous propose de les relever
et de faire briller ensemble la fierté
française je vous
remercie merci monsieur le Premier
ministre
merci dans la suite de notre débat je
vais maintenant donner la parole aux
orateurs de group le premier orateur est
le président Bruno rotillot pour le
group les
républicains la parole monsieur le
Président chers collègues Monsieur le
Premier
Ministre votre nomination à cont
establement une dimension
symbolique la jeunesse dont vous vous
réclamez et que vous revendiquer
l'audace aussi
que vous portez comme une bannière
évoque dans l'esprit de certain et
peut-être d'abord dans l'esprit du chef
de l'État les premiers matins
ensoleillés d'un macronisme
triomphant lorsqu'il fallait penser
printemps mais ces jours-là sont loin
désormais nous sommes en hiver et face
aux crises qui se multiplient et parfois
s'emboîent les unes dans les autres tel
la crise de l'agriculture les Français
seront achachés non pas cette portée
symbolique d'une nomination mais à la
politique que vous allez conduire que
vous allez mener avec votre gouvernement
car l'engouement dont vous bénéficier
encore
encore est un atout mais ce n'est pas un
AC
qui vous savez plaire mais saurez-vous
faire saurez-vous faire d'ailleurs ce
que vous nous promettez ce que le
président de la République nous a promis
une politique de réarmement et je
voudrais commencer mon intervention par
cette politique de réarmement parce
qu'on ne peut pas faire une bonne
politique sans bon
constat j'ai entendu euh le 31 décembre
comme beaucoup d'autres d'entre nous le
président de la République parlait et se
satisfaire se vter d'un réarement
économique
vraiment vraiment on est loin du plein
emploi le taux de chômage ne recule pas
il progresse il tengenttera les 8 % à la
fin de l'année et nous sommes à la
traain de l'Europe l'Allemagne est un
peu plus de 3 % peut-on s'en contenter
peut-on s'en satisfaire on est loin
aussi de la réindustrialisation c'est
vrai vous l'avez souligné ici à ma place
il y a quelques instants la
désindustrialisation sans doute stoppé
mais on est très loin de la
réindustrialisation la preuve le
commerce extérieur là encore quand on se
compare on se désole avantdernier des
pays
européens avec l'Espagne juste derrière
nous l'Espagne quant aux finances
publiques vous avez perdu le contrôle là
aussi ce n'est pas avec l'Espagne c'est
avec la Belgique qu'on partage le
presque dernier an l'avant-dernier an
beaucoup de pays pays européens sont
désormais dans leur taux d'endettement
un taux d'endettement inférieur à 65 %
du PIB vous avez indiqué que vous
maîtrisiez la dépense non avec le
rapporteur général nous l'avons encore
il y a quelques mois montré la dépense
n'est pas maîtrisée elle continue
d'augmenter et nous sommes à la traain
de l'Europe bien sûr et malheureusement
le problème français c'est que nous
cumulons des records de dépenses
publiques des records de prélèvement
obligatoirees et des serv des services
publics qui s'effondrent s'il y avait
une corrélation chers collègues entre le
niveau de la dépense publique et la
qualité des services publics mais alors
on serait à l'avantgarde du bonheur
universel et ça n'est pas le cas loin
sen faux de fil en aiguille et de
déficit en déficit qu'est-ce qui se
passe c'est la dette qui ne cesse
d'augmenter là encore seule la Grèce et
l'Italie font moins bien que la France
son font moins bien que nous et ça place
la France dans une situation extrêmement
périilleuse pourquoi parce qu'avec une
croissance qui est molle une croissance
potentielle qui faiblit parce que la
productivité est en train de s'effondré
depuis 2019 les taux d'intérêt réel à
long terme remontent et vont nous placer
dans cette situation que je décris comme
périlleuse au moment où toute l'activité
toute la richesse produite de la France
devra servir uniquement justement au
service de la dette et quen sera-t-il
des marge de manœuvre dont nous avons
besoin cruellement besoin pour faire
face au défis au chocs le choc
démographique vous avez très peu parlé
du vieillissement si peu parler de la
datalité le choc géopolitique le choc du
réchauffement climatique je vous ai
entendu dire euh hier que la
planification écologique c'était
l'écologie populaire non l'écologie ne
doit pas être euh ne doit pas se faire
en tout cas sur le dos des plus modestes
d'entre nous je pense que c'est une
conviction que vous et moi on peut
partager qu'on doit partager mais très
franchement du point de vue du armement
économique en parler sans satisfaire
c'est comme une
hallucination je ne le vois pas nous ne
le voyons pas la France et des armées
voyons un moment puisque vous en avez
parlé il y a quelques instants
l'autorité le réarmement de l'État
l'autorité de l'État on a la
confirmation des chiffres qui ont été
publiés il y a quelques semaines par le
ministère de l'Intérieur catastrophique
par jour les coups et blessures ont
augmenté 1000 pratiquement 1000 actes de
coup des blessures quotidiennes les
violences sexuelles qui était une
priorité du quinquena annoncé comme
telle près de 240 par jour CER ce sont
des statistiques elles sont froides
elles sont désincarnées je vous assure
que les Français je vous assure que les
Français subissent ces statistiques dans
leur chair à travers eux-mêmes ou leurs
amis et leur famille et beaucoup de
Français trouvent que notre justice 70 %
n'est pas suffisamment ferme elle est
trop laxiste là encore ça n'est pas une
question de moyen c'est une question de
courage est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
renverser la table à renverser la table
par exemple en créant les courte peine
des peines minimales enfin des places de
prison êtes-vous là encore prêt à
renverser la table pour que enfin on ait
un régime pénal des pineurs des mineurs
adaptés à la dangerosité des nouveaux
ensuvagés qui sont souvent délinquants
ça c'est pas le rôle de l'école ça c'est
le rôle d'une justice
pénal donc là encore pas de réarmement
un mot des souverainetés la souveraineté
budgétaire financière simplement pour
dire je parle sur le contrôle d' notre
rapporteur général que notre dette est
détenue à peu près à moitié par des
étrangers Napoléon avait une phrase qui
illustre bien la situation de la
souveraineté budgétaire de la France la
main qui donne la main qui prête est
toujours au-dessus de la main qui reçoit
il peut pas y avoir de souveraineté
financière lorsque on est si dépendant
de l'étranger et la voix de la France si
affaiblie en Europe n'alllez pas
chercher plus loin un pays qui ne tient
pas sa dette qui ne tient pas seses ses
comptes c'est une nation qui ne peut pas
tenir son rang et dont la voix
s'affaiblit dans le concert justement et
notamment européen on a parlé beaucoup
d'agriculture je vaux en parler quelques
instants le malaise des agriculteurs
vient tout simplement qu'on les a
enfermé dans une tenaille impossible
intonal intonable et qui pousse au
suicide un trop grand nombre d'entre eux
toujours plus de liberté à
l'extérieur
d'ultralibéralisme et toujours plus de
dirigisme à l'intérieur ce sont les noes
barbares du dirigisme à l'intérieur en
France et du libre échangisme à
l'extérieur c'est ce qui crée
aujourd'hui ce mal-être vous avez dit je
veux créer une sorte d'exception
agricole française la seule exception
agricole que connaissent aujourd'hui en
France nos agriculteurs c'est
l'exception normative c'est ce qui les
tu à petit fait parce que on importe une
agriculture en France qu'on interdit
justement sans doute pour préserver
l'environnement et notre santé
évidemment à nos agriculteurs de
produire vous avez les moyens vous avez
parlé de surtransposition prenez tout de
suite un décret interdisez tout de suite
ou plutôt acceptez tout de suite les
molécules qui sont elles interdites en
France mais autorisé en Espagne en
Allemagne en Europe rétablissz
une juste concurrence vous pouvez le
faire et il faut être conséquent votre
groupe au Parlement européen a voté
toutes les mesures de contrainte
environnementaliste de nos
agriculteurs il faut être conséquent
Emmanuel Macron veut le fédéralisme le
fédéralisme comment vouloir le
fédéralisme le fédéralisme chers
collègues c'est que toutes les décisions
soient pris de plus en plus à la
majorité majorité qualifiée et il
voudrait pour le Mercosur à lui seur
empêcher l'Europe d'avancer mais
l'Europe avance sans lui vous ne nous
avez pas permis ici de dire notre
opposition au CTA vous l'avez fait à
l'assemblée qui l'a ratifié grâce
notamment à V majorité ici nous voulons
voter contre le CA nous sommes cohérents
nous sommes conséquents parce que nous
voulons préserver précisément la
souveraineté de la
France j'ajoute à ce panorama pour
terminer le bilan un bilan que vous
trouviez solide le bilan politique
jamais le rassemblement national n'a été
aussi élevé dans les sondages jamais il
n'a été aussi proche d'une prise de
pouvoir pourquoi
Emmanuel Macron avait indiqué qu'il
était le rempart il se posait comme le
rempart il n aurait été que le
march-pied parce qu'à force parce qu'à
force d'organiser méticuleusement un
face- àface avantageux vous le faites
grimper bien sûr dans les sondage alors
voyez ce bilan il n'est pas solide il
est liquide vous voulez réarmer la
France soit soit
nous le voulons nous aussi mais
n'attendez pas de nous que nous
devenions macronistes vous dites j'ai
confiance nous n'avons pas confiance
nous avons appris à nous méfier
aujourd'hui il faudra que cette
confiance vous puissiez la reconstruire
parce qu'aujourd'hui le sentiment qui
domine ici c'est précisément la défiance
mais nous ne serons jamais macroniste
parce que voyez nous sommes les héritier
du général de Gaulle et nous pensons que
sur la pratique des institutions comme
de la vision la politique le macronisme
est un antigolisme sur d'abord les
institutions un gouvernement qui ne
détermine plus qui ne conduit plus la
politique de la nation un parlement
totalement anémié on a parlé vous avez
parlé de la loi immigration j'en reviens
une loi censurée qui n'aurait jamais été
votée ni dans l'une ni dans l'autre des
assemblées une loi promulguée une loi
censurée qui été votée très
majoritairement ici à et une loi au
contraire censurée qui n'aurait jamais
été votée dans aucune de nos de
assemblées et laame vous allez
contourner à nouveau le Parlement avec
la voie règlementaire c'est un parlement
qui n'a jamais été aussi diminué à coup
d'ordonnance qui ne sont plus ratifié à
coup de règlement de lois qui ne sont
plus appliqué et de 493 maises chers
collègues le problème de cette pratique
institutionnelle c'est que bien sûr ces
instruments de coertition sont dans la
Constitution mais le général de GA comme
Michel debr croyait non pas à la
concentration des pouvoirs en un seul
mais au contraire pour reprendre la
formule de debr à la collaboration des
pouvoirs aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron use
de ces pouvoirs coercitifs sans avoir la
contrepartie c'est-à-dire le recours au
référendum ou même au peuple voilà
pourquoi il y a un point qui est
déséquilibre notre vie politique et
notre démocratie et puis la vision de la
politique de avait cette phrase la
politique c'est l'action pour un idéal à
travers des réalités l'action désormais
a été supplantée par la communication
c'est terrible plus la politique est
impuissante puis elle se perd dans la
surcommunication euh à force de vouloir
crever l'écran la politique en crève
l'idéal l'idéal battu en brèche par
l'opportunisme mes chers collègues le
débauchage le débauchage ne fait ni de
bien à la démocratie ni de bien ni de
bien à la politique parce que signifiait
que tout se vaut la droite comme la
gauche la fidélité comme les revirements
ça veut dire que rien ne vaut et que
tout est faux et je m'honore qu'ici au
Sénat il y ait des femmes des hommes de
loyauté à gauche comme à droite qui
considéront toujours que l'ambition est
en dessous de la conviction la
conviction au-dessus de
l'ambition quant à la réalité qu à la
réalité président de la République dire
que les émeutes c'est parce que les
jeunes étaient oisifs franchement les
Français n'ont pas compris alors
Monsieur le Premier Ministre la tâche
est herculéenne la fonction est
difficile quand un premier ministre
existe il inquiète quand il n'existe pas
il manque mais justement nous traversons
un moment tlurique et dans un moment
tlurique on peut pas simplement
continuer les bilans on peut pas
simplement faire des ajustements ajuster
faire quelques petite mesure il faut
revoir les principes des principes
nouveaux ce que vous n'avez pas dit ici
à cette tribune et c'est ce que nous
attendons en revanche vous a entendu
vous voulez vous adresser aux Français
ordinaire pourquoi pas mais alors
adressez-vous à nos compatriotes non pas
dans la langue du marketing de la
segmentation catégorielle mais
parlez-leur comme un seul peuple
parlez-leur la langue de l'unité
abandonner le en même temps rompez avec
le macronisme vous voulez parler à tous
ces Français ordinaires mais alors
faites comme le général de Gaulle
pratiquez la politique de la majorité
nationale rendez au français ordinaires
rendez à cette France là bien sûr cette
capacité cette liberté cette liberté
cette école cette école qui instruisent
et qui ne déconstruisent pas rendez-lui
ce travail bien sûr au-delà de la
spicardisation rendez-lui sa
souveraineté rendez au Mair évidemment
cette liberté les maires ne demandent
pas l'omô les maires souffrent du même
mal que les agriculteurs ce mal c'est
l'overdose de norm les maires veulent un
réarmement civique parce que eux sont au
service de la cité la cité le civisme et
puis les maires rendez à cette France-
là ses frontières pour que elle puisse
se protéger rendez-lui sa souveraineté
c'est-à-dire sa liberté en résumé rendez
aux Français ordinaires des raisons
d'espérer dans la France cette France
que nous aimons et cette France que nous
voulons servir de tout notre cœur merci
de votre
attention
la
parole la parole est au président
Patrick
canner pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
[Applaudissements]
républicain
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier ministre mes chers collègues le
9 janvier dernier vous avez accepté la
mission que vous a confié Emmanuel
Macron à la tête du
gouvernement ce jour-là vous avez
accepté d'endosser un lourd passif celui
d'une politique libérale et
réactionnaire mené depuis bientôt 7 ans
vous avez aussi accepté dansendosser une
lourde responsabilité celle de conduire
ce rouleau compresseur d'injustice et de
casse sociale vos premières semaines à
Matignon en sont l'édifiant témoignage
des blindés sur les autoroutes une école
publique insultée une facture
d'électricité qui explose la franchise
médicale doublé rien ne semble vous
arrêter pourtant je vous le dis les
Français sont à bout je ne parle pas des
plus riches d'entre eux qui peuvent
continuer à s'enrichir sans limite sans
scrupule je parle de celles et ceux qui
ne peuvent compter que sur leur travail
pour vivre et qui galère vous ne le
voyez pas ou vous ne voulez pas le voir
ces Français sont épuisés par la
politique que vous menez depuis 2017
vous ne voulez pas voir qu'ils ont élu
Emmanuel Macron par deux fois pour faire
barrage à l'extrême droite ils ne lui
ont pas donner le mandat pour dérouler
cette politique de régression les
élections législatives et sénatoriales
ont déjà sanctionné votre politique la
prochaine étape ce sera le 9 juin lors
des élections européennes ce contexte
aurait dû vous conduire à un réflexe
écoute voire d'humilité dans votre
exercice du pouvoir à privilégier la
concertation le dialogue social la
réalité est tout autre ne parvenant pas
à emporter l'adhésion des Français vous
avez fait le choix du passage en force
permanent et de l'utilisation
déraisonnée du 49 alinéa 3 pire vous
avez démontré que vous étiez prêt à
fragiliser notre État de droit pour
parvenir à vos fins en feignant de
satisfaire les appétits pour ne pas dire
les fantasmes de la droite sur la loi
immigration vous êtes cyniquement
défaussé sur le Conseil constitutionnel
vous avez ouvert la voix à la remise en
cause de nos institutions et de notre
Constitution et je le dis ici jamais je
n'oublierai les propos irresponsables
tenus par la droite dite républicaine à
leur rencontre ces propos m'ont indigné
je les condamne avec force comme je
condamne la responsabilité du Président
de la République dans cette grave dérive
ce jeul-là est dangereux et nous en
sortons tous perdants tous sauf celles
qui s'en frotent à les mains l'extrême
droite la même extrême droite qui se
réjouit de votre bilan depuis 7 ans qui
se délecte de voir nos service public
mise à mal nos cors intermédiaires
ignorer la fracturation sociale assumer
l'extrême droite qui n'a plus qu'à
déambuler sereinement sur le tapis rouge
que vous lui déroulez monsieur le
Premier ministre je fais partie de ceux
qui croient que notre pays peut résister
à la tentation brune et nausé àonde de
l'extrême droite pas par principe pas
simplement par l'attachement des
Français à nos valeurs républicaines car
les valeurs républain we on en a rien à
faire qu'on n pas quand on n' pas les
moyens de nourrir correctement ses
enfants quand on voit que les efforts
reposent toujours sur les mêmes je vous
en pris retirez vos illères et cessz
d'alimenter le Terrot des populistes
monsieur le Premier ministre nous sommes
ici dans la chambre des territoires vous
avez en face de vous des parlementaires
en contact permanent avec nos élus
locaux des élus locaux qui mieux que
quiconque entendent l'amertume des
Français qui d'élection en élection voit
de plus en plus de leurs habitants qui
partent dépit se laissent tenter par le
RN ces élus sont aujourd'hui en colère
ils sont en colère parce qu'ils sont en
première ligne auprès de nos concitoyens
qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens de répondre
à leurs besoins ils sont en colère parce
que l'attente était forte parce que le
Président de la République s'était
engagé à ouvrir une nouvelle donne
territoriale qu'en reste-t-il
aujourd'hui depuis votre arrivé au
pouvoir les collectivités territoriales
ont été considéré par le gouvernement
comme une variable d'ajustement des
comptes publics chaque jour les élus que
je rend compte m'alerte sur les
conséquences de votre politique fiscale
avec pour seul d'homme la diminution des
impôts la suppression de la CVAE en est
le dernier exemple plus de transfert de
compétences mais moins de moyens les
élus locaux sont aussi en colère face à
votre immobilisme en matière de
décentralisation la loi 3DS censé
représenter un nouvel acte en la matière
ne fut qu'un rendez-vous manqué comme si
l'excès de centralisation n'avait pas
montré ses limites de la crise des
gilets jaunes à la crise sanitaire notre
groupe croit en la force de l'État et
des collectivités qui assure l'unité
nationale et l'égalité entre les
citoyens qu'il se trouveent sur
l'hexagone ou sur les outr mères si
l'État est garant de ces principes
l'état centralisateur ne peut en
garantir seul l'efficacité et nous avons
des idées d'abord donner une bouffée
d'oxygène aux élus indexer la dotation
globale de fonctionnement sur
l'inflation renforcer la dotation pour
l'exercice des mandats locaux et parce
que les finances locales doivent être
sécurisées nous voulons aller plus loin
nous vous demandons une loi de
financement des collectivités
territoriales elle permettrait de
définir de manière plannuelle les grands
enjeux de l'investissement local et
d'assurer l'autonomie financière des
collectivités territoriales enfin nous
voulons un statut pour l'élu cela a été
évooquer intimidation violence agression
et ce paroxisme extraordinaire du mois
de juin dernier avec les révoltes
urbaines incandescence qui nous alertent
et qui exigent des réponses fortes et
j'y viens d'abord d'abord remettre la
justice au cœur de nos politiques
publiques depuis 2017 les droits c'est
pour les nantis les devoirs c'est pour
les petits je crois monsieur le Premier
ministre que vous ne mesurez pas les
conséquences de ce sentiment d'injustice
chez nos concitoyens vous ne mesurez pas
le malaise et le ressentiment que cela
peut provoquer c'est un élu du Nord qui
vous le dit d'un territoire que le
déclassement conduit au désespoir un
désespoir que vos politiques continue
d'amplifier comment comprendre quand on
a peine à boucler ces fins de mois que
des multin national enregistre des
bénéfices records dans les secteurs du
pétrole du gaz des transports sans que
ces bénéfices ne viennent contribuer à
la solidarité nationale comment
comprendre que pendant ce temps-là vous
augmentez de 10 % la facture
d'électricité des Français comment
comprendre l'explosion des hauts revenus
exonérés d'impôt sur la fortune les
seules réponses que vous apportez ce
sont des primes pardonnez-moi monsieur
le Premier ministre mais si elles
apportent une réponse d'urgence
bienvenue pour les Français les plus
modestes ces primes sont avant du
bricolage on ne gouverne pas un pays à
coup de rustine qui n'apporte aucune
réponse de long terme là encore puisque
vous semblez à cours d'idée en voici
quelques-unes mettez en place une taxe
sur les super profits dans les secteurs
de l'énergie des transports instaurer un
ISF climatique ou encore éétablisser les
impôts de production il s'agit là de
répondre à un besoin réel renflouer les
caisses de l'État pour financer des
politiques publiques pour tous il s'agit
aussi d'un signal qui n'est pas que
symbolique non les CL classe moyenne
n'ont pas à supporter tous les efforts
ces efforts doivent être répartis
suivant les moyens de chacun voilà une
ambition politique nouvelle car les
Français ne demandent pas l'Ô ils
demandent de vivre dignement de leur
travail Vous vous targuez d'avoir de
d'avoir diminuer le taux de chômage mais
vous avez augmenté le nombre de
travailleurs pauvres vous avez favorisé
un marché du travail au service des
entreprises sans contrepartie pour les
salariés la baisse du chômage ne dit
rien des difficultés croissantes de nos
concitoyens à se nourrir se loger se
chauffer se soigner vous dites
vouloir difficile
dmicardiser la France mais quel aveu qui
est responsable de ce smicardisation
quand elle concerne 17 % des salariés
français nul ne peut se prévaloir de sa
propre turpitude contrairement à vous
nous ne proposons pas une nouvelle
baisse des charges mais une véritable
politique de revalorisation salarial
pour chaque citoyen et qu'il soit
justement rémunéré une juste
rémunération pour mieux vivre et en
premier lieu se loger vous n'avez aucune
vision pour la politique du logement la
dérégulation ne constitue pas une
politique Monsieur le Premier Ministre
tout le secteur économique de la
construction subit une crise sans
précédent avec des entreprises et des
emplois menacés des élus locaux désarmé
en réponse Vous avez sapé le modèle
économique du logement social et
maintenant vous vous attaquez désormais
au fondement de la loi SRU c'est
irresponsable ce que nous proposons
d'abord réhabiliter la construction en
ville comme en milieu rural et si
l'objectif du zan est essentiel il doit
être équilibré avec les aspirations des
Français et coconstruit avec les élus
locaux ensuite repenser la place des
collectivités dans les politiques de
logement pour permettre l'adaptation
locale nécessaire renforcer leurs moyens
leur donner des outils propres de
régulation favoriser une reprise de la
construction de logement avec une
maîtrise de l' volée des prix du foncier
et la généralisation de l'encadrement
des loyers ne serait-ce que dans les
zones tendues et enfin réévaluer les APL
oui notre pays s'enfonce vers une
fracturation de la société qui atteindra
bientôt un point de long retour et le
monde agricole nous en donne une
nouvelle illustration la mobilisation
des agriculteurs est aujourd'hui une
expression flagrante de cette colère qui
gronde une colère qui trouve ses
origines dans une crise structurelle
appelant à des réformes d'ampleur votre
gouvernement manque une nouvelle fois
d'une vision d'ensemble et d'un projet
mobilisateur ce que nous proposons une
véritable transition de notre modèle
agricole vers davantage de durabilité et
de reconnaissance du travail rendu
conditions indispensables pour pour
offrir des perspectives justes à nos
agriculteurs c'est l'objectif monsieur
le Premier ministre monsieur le
Président de la commission d'enquête que
nous réclamons sur la question des
revenus agricoles et des relations
commerciales à gros alimentaire il est
temps qu'un diagnostic clair précis
transparent soit posé sur des pratiques
de certains opérateurs économiques afin
de mettre fin à un système qui tue à
petit feu notre agriculture les annonces
que vous avez faites hier et encore
aujourd'hui ne sont pas du niveau pour
conclure je souhaite évoquer les
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
seront demain avec nous à gauche dans la
rue pour défendre notre école publique
laïque et gratuite car aujourd'hui vous
la mettez en danger vous continuez de la
fragiliser en supprimant des postes
d'enseignant encore 650 cette année
comble du cynisme votre Ministre accuse
ensuite l'école publique d'être
responsable d'une fragilité que vous
avez provoqué enfin de compte quelle est
votre vision pour l'école brandir
lestendards du choc des savoirs ne fait
pas une politique publique ce qui ronge
aujourd'hui l'école c'est l'absence de
mixité sociale ce qui ronge notre
société c'est le séparatisme dès le plus
jeune âge face à cela que proposez-vous
vous prenez le retour de l'uniforme à
l'école la labellisation des manuels
scolaires et le placement en internat
une vision étriquée vieillote qui ne
répond qu'à une seule logique
l'autoritarisme plutôt que la pédagogie
Monsieur le Premier Ministre hier vous
avez affirmé je vous
cite que vous voyez davantage de raisons
d'espérer que de
douter permettez-moi de vous dire
Monsieur le Premier Ministre que l'on
doute de la place de la France sur le
plan international que l'on doute de
votre attachement à la démocratie et à
nos institutions que l'on doute de votre
capacité a assurer notre souveraineté
oui que l'on doute de votre gouvernement
macrosiste l'illusion
macroniste du social libéralisme de 2017
aura duré un
printemps aucun enseignement n'a été
tiré des multiples crises sociales dans
ces deux quinquenas le libéralisme
antisocial du président de la République
ne trompe plus personne vous n'avez fait
que semer les graine de la colère qui
sont en train de germer sur le terraot
de vos choix de société et votre
vocabulaire guerrier n'est que le signe
avant tout d'une grande faiblesse les
relants réactionnaires et la course
folle aux alliances opportunistes ont le
don non seulement de nous faire douter
mais nous oblige surtout à agir pour les
Françaises pour les Français notre
groupe portera et portera des solutions
celle d'un avenir solidaire et durable
je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant au
président Hervé
Marseille pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste monsieur le
président
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames les ministres
mes chers collègues effectivement hier
nous avons écouté ici en stéréo votre
discours lu avec beaucoup de conviction
et de tonicité par Monsieur le Ministre
de
l'économie c'est un exercice sacrificiel
auquel nous
compatissons monsieur le Premier
ministre vous avez bien fait de venir
aujourd'hui pour préciser les
nous avons retenu quand même des phrases
en France tout est possible en le disant
vous pensez à ce qui peut être positif
bien sûr mais malheureusement ça marche
dans les deux sens et la France est
effectivement capable du meilleur mais
aussi de performance moins enviable pour
faire du tout est possible une formule
de confiance et d'espoir nous avons
apprécié votre capacité à aborder tous
les sujets y compris ceux qui fâchent
qui irritent au quotidien ou plus
largement le sentiment d'impuissance
l'action publique poison de notre
démocratie quant à vos orientations
cardinales dmicardisé déverrouillé
débureaucratisé comment ne pas y
souscrire ces grands axes vous les
mettez au service du réarmement de notre
pays permettez un vieux matou né en
54 de vous proposer un autre terme bien
plus classique mais plus important à mes
yeux celui de justice réarmé sans doute
nécessaire mais pour une finé servir la
justice car c'est le sentiment
d'injustice et d'inéquité qui fragilise
aujourd'hui notre société la colère
agricole on vient d'en parler en est la
caricature les agriculteurs sont au
carrefour d'une quadruple injustice
territoriale d'abord opp positionition
accrue d'un monde qui se sent abandonné
déclassé économique les agriculteurs
sont les parents pauvres du partage de
la de la valeur sociale et culturelle
celle des travailleurs de ceux qui se
lèv tôt face aux injonctions d'école
blancs hors sol l'injustice de vivre
avec le sentiment de devoir abandonner
ses valeurs enfin justice injustice face
à des normes et des contraintes
françaises ou européennes qui ne pèsent
pas sur leurs concurrents d'autres pays
chez nous l'injustice commence dès la
naissance elle dépend du milieu mais
aussi du lieu où l'on vient au monde le
président de la République l'a reconnu
nous ne garantissons pas l'égalité de
tous les enfants de la République et
pour cause aujourd'hui naître à la
campagne c'est souvent naître dans un
désert médical là résist sans doute
actuellement l'injustice territoriale la
plus insupportable or vous l'avez
justement souligné nous ne pouvons pas
attendre gentiment que la fin du numérus
closis produise ses effets régulariser
les médecins étrangers n'y suffira même
pas il faudra avoir le courage et vous
venez de le dire à l'instant d'élargir
les délégations d'acte par
expérimentmentation plus globalement
pour tâcher de remédier à l'injustice
territoriale le Sénat PLA pour une
décentralisation régénérée qui restitue
des marges aux collectivités qui
insuffle plus d'équité que d'égalités
formel tel est l'esprit de la
différenciation que nous appelons de nos
vœux vos mots sont encourageants la
décentralisation n'a pas la place qui
doit lui revenir gageons que vos
propositions permettent d'avancer nous
espérons que votre arrivée signe la fin
de ce rendez-vous manqué avec les
collectivités depuis tant d'années
l'école est aussi un lieu d'injustice
persistante certes on a restreint le
nombre d'élèves par classe dans les
zones prioritaires mais temps reste à
faire bien sûr l'instruction civique
c'est important nous aussi nous sommes
favorables au retour de l'uniforme mais
le véritable enjeu c'est le retour du
mérite de l'excellence du respect des
enseignants pour y parvenir l'école a
besoin d'un CAP clair comme vous l'avez
fortement comme vous l'avez justement
déclaré tout n'est pas question de
moyens il n'y avait pas besoin d'argent
pour abandonner la méthode globale prené
pendant des décennies par des idéologues
dans cette France où tout est possible
le sentiment d'injustice habite aussi
les classes moyennes celles qui
contribuent sans recevoir comme vous
l'avez dit cela ne peut plus durer ceci
appelle de ma part deux remarques
d'abord les fiscalités de l'immobilier
et des successions sont les plus mal
vécus par les classes moyennes votre
ouverture dans leur direction doit être
l'occasion d'évoluer dans cette matière
ensuite la fraude sociale et fiscale est
au cœur de leur malaise nos concitoyens
méritant ne peuvent plus supporter de
voir d'un côté les prestations sociales
méticuleusement détourné et de l'autre
une poignée d'entreprise voyou s'exiler
pour échapper à toute contribution aux
charges publi il faut mener une guerre
sans merci à la fraude et à l'évasion
sous toutes ses formes l'injustice se
vit aussi de plus en plus dans la
question du logement nous alertons
depuis des mois sur la crise qui vient
elle est désormais présente vous avez
déclaré vouloir la prendre à bras le cor
cependant il n'est pas certain que la
simplif iation des normes la réquisition
des bâtiments V ou l'intégration du
logement intermédiaire dans les critères
de la loi et ses rues suffiront ce sont
des mesures pertinente qui était attendu
mais plusieurs de centaines de milliers
de logements manquent aujourd'hui
comment se dégager du foncier avec les
problèmes du zan en particulier vous
l'avez souligné il faudra adapter le zan
dans son application tout ne pourra pas
reposer sur la seule densification la
transition écologique soulève également
un enjeu majeur de justice et d'équité
car cette transition aussi vitale et
nécessaire soit-elle va faire des
perdants je pense en particulier aux
petits propriétaires qui vont être
plombés par le DPE ou aux artisans que
les a et feu vont empêcher de travailler
Monsieur le Premier Ministre l'injustice
se niche jusque dans les derniers jours
de la vie la dépendance est l'un des
défis majeurs qu'il nous faut relever
aujourd'hui avec le vieillissement de la
population c'est toute la société qui
doit se
réinventer nous ne pouvons pourtant plus
procrastiner
le modèle social et financier est au
bord de l'implosion c'est maintenant
qu'il faut agir enfin les inégalités et
les injustices sont
intergénérationnel ce qui pose
aujourd'hui la question de la dette et
des déficits s'il nous faut maîtriser la
trajectoire de nos finances publiques
c'est bien sûr pour recouvrir des marges
de manœuvre mais c'est aussi pour
rétablir une équité intergénérationnelle
or nous n'en prenons pas le chemin cette
année notre pays devra emprunter 285
milliards d'euros c'est plus que le PIB
du Portugal et la charge de la dette
devra bondir de 50 % d'ici à
2027 maîtriser les dépenses c'est bien
sûr faire des économies mais c'est
surtout faire des réformes de structure
sans attendre le retour des vaches
grasses pour terminer revenons à votre
état civil si vous le permettez Monsieur
le Premier Ministre car nous pouvions
attendre d'un jeune chef du gouvernement
qu'il nous ouvre sur le futur qu' nous
parle d'intelligence artificielle
d'hydrogène vert d'espace de génétique
de ce ce monde en transformation pour ne
pas dire en ébullition sur lequel nous
devons nous
repositionner on n a pas parlé parce que
vous êtes nous sommes rattrapés par les
problèmes du passé que nous n'avons pas
pu résoudre pourtant vous avez cherché à
nous transmettre l'essentiel l'optimisme
et la détermination comme vous nous
savons que notre avenir sera européen ou
ne sera pas ce qui n'interdit pas d'être
critique vis-à-vis de l'Europe que l'on
a construite trop technocratique et qui
n'est pas celle dont nous rêvions
Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous êtes
ici au Sénat et depuis les législatives
de 2022 c'est ici pour l'essentiel qu'on
fabrique les principales lois sans le
Sénat pas de réforme des retraites sans
le Sénat pas de loi
d'immigration dès votre nomination vous
êtes venu à la rencontre du Sénat en
participant à la conférence des
présidents nous avons été sensibles à ce
geste qui constitue un encouragement mes
collègues Bruno Raillot et Patrick
canner ont eu l'occasion de vous dire à
ce moment précis que comme nous ils
étaient ouverts au dialogue mais hostile
à la coconstruction c'est-à-dire à
l'association des parlementaires à
l'élaboration du projet de loi avant son
dépôt au Parlement car cette méthode lit
les parlementaires sans leur permettre
de véritablement enrichir ou modifier
les textes en revanche nous sommes
favorables à la construction
parlementaire lors de l'examen des
textes c'est la différence entre
coconstruction et construction
d'ailleurs
si les textes ont été votés depuis 2 ans
c'est bien parce qu'il y a eu des
compromis des accords des constructions
qui ont permis d'aboutir face à notre
impuissance nous n'avons plus les moyens
de chercher des responsables que ce soit
le Conseil constitutionnel Bruxelles les
institutions judiciaires nous devons
supporter 3000 milliards de dettes les
agriculteurs bloquent les routes
l'inflation ronge le pouvoir d'achat la
guerre frappe aux portes de l'Europe
efface peu à peu l'Arménie de la carte
et embrase le Proche Orient avec l'ombre
inquiétante de l'Iran et le possible
retour de Donald Trump nous pensons que
le dialogue avec le Parlement et
singulièrement avec le Sénat doit être
fertile nous devons nous écouter et nous
devons rechercher les solutions les plus
collectifes possibles alors Monsieur le
Premier Ministre cette responsabilité
elle pèse sur vos épaules elle pèse
aussi sur nos épaules si vous échouez si
nous échouons vous et nous savons qui
arbitrera nos différents en 2027 et
alors il sera trop tard pour pleurer sur
le lait renversé je vous
remercieur
président la parole est au président
François patria pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes
indépendant
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues chers
collègues nous avons écouté dans le
calme vos contestations sans appel
permettez à ceux qui ont aussi des
convictions et qui les placent bien
au-dessus de leur ambition de pouvoir
s'exprimer aussi pour dire que nous
n'avons pas la même vision bien
évidemment la politique la politique est
l'art d'imaginer et de construire un
projet
collectif ce projet le président de la
République
on a posé les jalons depuis 2017 et les
Français lui ont renouvelé leur
conscience le confiance en 2022 afin de
le poursuivre lors des législatives de
2022 les Français ont adressé un message
aux élus de la nation ils appelaient à
un dialogue et à un travail concerté
avec la majorité présidentielle
malheureusement nous nous sommes trop
souvent heurtés au refus du compromis
politique à la différence du Sénat
attaché à la culture du dialogue
républicain l'assemblée nationale n'a
pas su cultiver cet état d'esprit la
majorité plurielle s'est affirmée avant
tout comme une majorité d'empêchement la
minorité plurielle comme une majorité
d'empêchement et c'est et en refusant
toute main tendue marquant ainsi son
devoir vis-à-vis des Français notre
devoir monsieur le Premier ministre
c'est de poursuivre le projet de réforme
aux profondeurs de notre pays qui peut
rester qui ne peut rester statiqu alors
que les crises se multiplient sur
l'ensemble de la planète face à ces
crises vous nous avez appelé monsieur le
Premier ministre à construire ensemble
et abandonner des postures politiciennes
vous nous avez appelé à agir plutôt qu'à
réagir dans l'intérêt des Français je
partage de votre analyse je partage
aussi la fierté du chemin parcouru
depuis 7 ans votre nomination est une
nouvelle étape nous en conservant le
même cap libéré protégé transformer unir
monsieur le Premier ministre vous avez
la lourde tâche de veiller à la
traduction en acte concret la volonté
réformatrice formulée par le Président
vous nous avez rappelé que la France
n'est pas pas une nation qui subit elle
ne l'a pas été elle ne l'est pas
aujourd'hui elle ne lera pas demain
grâce à notre travail vous souhaitez
agir vite en faisant preuve de lucidité
de pragmatisme d'efficacité et d'audace
votre méthode est simple et efficace
prendre rapidement des décisions
compréhensibles pour les Français et
vous l'avez démontré vendredi lors de
votre visite dans le Sud-Ouest en effet
cette méthode est déjà à l'épreuve la
crise que traverse le monde agricole est
symptommatique des mots français des
mots français parce que la
bureaucratisation et l'empilement des
normes particulièrement denses ont
entretenu le malêtre d'une profession
qui a souvent été mal présentée mal
comprise mal et qui et qui en souffre
des mots qui dépassent nos frontières
aussi parce que les mêmes causes ont les
mêmes les mêmes effets chez nos voisins
européens cette crise agricole à
d'autres racines je pense au
concurrences déloyal vous l'avez évoqué
à la nécessité d'instaurer des clauses
miroir dans les traités internationaux
je pense aussi à la complexification
notre objectif et de garder notre notre
souveraineté alimentaire et vos annonces
depuis vendredi vont dans ce sens aller
aller à la transition écologique à la
souveraineté al alimentaire et agricole
alli la transition écologique pardon et
la souveraineté alimentaire agricole
c'est ça l'exception agricole française
que nous devons défendre mais cette
trans transition doit être supportable
tant par les producteurs que par les
consommateurs reconquérir une
souveraineté perdue est notre devoir
assumé depuis 2017 il faut poursuivre
dans la souveraineté industrielle car
vous l'avez rappelé nous créons
aujourd'hui plus d'emplois que nous en
détruisons dans le secteur industriel et
nous réouvrons des usines de la
souveraineté énergétique car nous avons
entrepris de relancer la filière
nucléaire alors que nous avions perdu
l'habitude de mettre en service des
centrales dans la souveraineté militaire
puisque nous avons voté la dernière LPM
ici une des plus importantes hausses du
budget des armées que notre pays est
connu afin de faire face aux multiples
fronts et de formes de confrontation
aujourd'hui dans la souveraineté à NS
front entière avec le renforcement de
notre arsenal législatif mais aussi la
notre capacité d'intégration j'ai ici
une pensée pour le territoire de Mayotte
qui fait face à une crise migratoire
sans précédent à laquelle la fermeté
doit répondre en effet mes chers
collègues nos outres mères font le
rayonnement de la France à travers le
monde mais sont trop souvent les parents
pauvres de nos politiques publiques
leurs difficultés sont décuplé par leur
situation géographique leurs
problématiques sont à la fois les mêmes
que dans l'Hexagone mais leur intensité
est parfois plus en Guyane où la
protection du territoire de sa
biodiversité de nos frontières coûte
encore la vie à nos militaires à qui
nous pensons aujourd'hui aux Antilles où
la crise des Sargasses et de la clor
descon handicape les territoires qui
doiv faire face à la vie chère à walis
et Futuna territoire silinin où l'État
doit faire pour préserver le contrat
social en Polynésie qui devra dans les
années à venir faire face à la montée
des océans à l'extension de l'influence
chinoise dans le Pacifique à la réunion
qui a subi récemment le cyclone Béal un
des plus puissants que ceire que ce
territoire a été affronté et qui
malheureusement pourrait se répéter à
l'avenir avec le dérèglement climatique
face à l'urgence climatique on ne fera
pas d'écologie contre le peuple c'est au
contraire une écologie populaire avec
les Français qui réconcili le climat et
la croissance qui permettra de
construire la France du 21e siècle
l'écologie punitive ne fait
qu'entretenir la division là où nous
avons besoin d'union monsieur le Premier
ministre vous avez porté un message
force pour le mérite notre majorité a
toujours uvré pour que le travail pai en
2017 déjà nous avons baissé les
cotisations salariales pour que les
actifs gagnent rapidement pouvoir
d'achat c'é une mesure de bon sens sans
tracat pour les Français il nous faut
prolonger une politique qui mette en
valeur le travail les annonces que vous
avez formulé hier vont dans ce sens et
nous les saluons travail souveraineté
autorité voilà la lig la laine tracée
dans vos propos devant nous cet
après-midi rappelez celle d'hier voilà
ce qu'il nous faut collectivement
construire avec des élus locaux pour que
tous nos concitoyens gardent la
confiance et l'espoir monsieur le
Premier ministre vous avez voulu tracer
une feuille de route qui vous ressemble
pragmatique concise et structuré mais
vous n'avez pas oublié de faire prendre
racine dans le travail mené par vos
prédécesseurs ceux qui nous ont
accompagné avant je pense à Édouard
Philippe à Jean Castex vous les avez
cité hier à Élizabeth borne dont je veux
souligner ici l'action déterminée au
service de notre pays nous avons porté
ensemble des textes majeurs ces derniers
mois prendre racine dans le travail mené
par vos prédécesseurs c'est aussi
rappeler que tous les territoires ont
été concernés par nos réformes qu'ils
soient métropolitains urbains ou ruraux
contrairement à ce que j'entends la
ruralité n'a pas été oubliée et j'y vis
chaque chaque jour notamment ce qui
concerne le renforcement des services
publics de proximité nous avons
également investi fortement dans l'école
dans la santé dans la sécurité et dans
la justice aujourd'hui nous le savons il
faut accélérer je sais bien que le mot
réarmé vous fait sourire mais il
soulligne notre détermination à
renforcer notre pays en matière
académique sociale économique
technologique et innovante agir dans
cette direction c'est le choix de notre
indépendance et de notre souveraineté
mais c'est aussi faire le choix de la
solidarité et de l'attention aux autres
car une France plus forte c'est une
France plus juste notamment auprès des
classes moyennes dont vous avez fait
votre priorité c'est objectif d'une
France plus forte et plus juste je sais
qu'il est largement partagé par les élus
de tout bord nous avons en partage chers
collègues l'amour de ce pays et nous
savons que l'une des clés du succès pour
notre nation c'est de travailler avec le
gouvernement avec les élus les
partenaires sociaux les forces vive pour
assumer ensemble les grandes ambitions
nationales c'est ça aussi le dépassement
la crise suppose audace action
efficacité ces qualités mes chers
collègues aucune formation politique
n'en a le monopole c'est pourquoi j'en
appelle avec les sénateurs r des pays de
la métropole et d'outres m à l'esprit de
responsabilité qui nous anime dans cet
hémicycle et grâce auquel nous savons
conduire des débats nourris mais
constructifs et trouver ensemble des
voies d'accord alors Monsieur le Premier
Ministre vous nous avez appelé vous nous
avez rappelé le cap vous nous avez dit
la méthode nous savons votre
détermination vous connaissez notre
fidélité notre loyauté au prjet
présidentiel vous souhaitez être un
premier ministre de terrain nous serons
à vos côté je vous remercie merci
monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
Président la parole est à madame la
Présidente Cécile cuerman
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen écologiste
kalaki vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier ministre mes chers
collègues monsieur le Premier ministre
et malgré votre jeunesse vous n'êtes pas
un nouveau né dans l'entourage du
président Emmanuel Macron les crises
sont là Monsieur le Premier Ministre et
elle génère chez nos compatriotes une
angoisse renforcé de moins en moins
aggravé par la multiplication des
conflits sur la planète de tout temps la
peur qui marque les peuple c'est la
guerre nous qui portons ce combat au
cœur de notre action savons qu'il ne
peut y avoir de progrès social de
justice en temps de guerre ce grand
désordre du monde s'exprime en Ukraine
en Israël en Palestine et plus
particulièrement à Gaza mais aussi en
Arménie au Yémen au Kurdistan cette
situation exige que les nations les plus
influentes comme la nôtre déploient des
efforts considérables pour que la
diplomatie prévale à ce monde en crise
répondent des crises intérieures
profondes notre peuple souffre sur fond
d'inégalités financière et sociale
croissante la baisse du pouvoir d'achat
la crise de notre système de santé les
défaillance accélérée du service public
nuisent la confiance de nos concitoyens
dans l'avenir pour pour eux et pour
leurs enfants alors que 46 milliards
d'euros ont été remis aux actionnaires
du CAC 40 en 2023 un record 11 millions
de personnes ne mangent pas à leur fin
en France l'inflation dévastatrice 10 %
en 2 ans accélère cet appauvrissement
les chiffres de l'alimentaire vous les
connaissez mais il faut les répéter plus
12 % en moyenne plus 20 % pour nombre de
produits alimentaire de base et pourtant
les salaires ne suivent pas vous voulez
Monsieur le Premier
Ministre désmicardiser pardon on y
arrive vous voulez désmicardiser la
France mais vous ne proposez rien pour
augmenter les salaires vous culpabilisez
les salariés les chômeurs mais jamais
vous ne pointez la responsabilité
fondamentale des plus riches et
actionnaires de tout poil j'ai comme
nombre d'entre vous assist à de
nombreuses cérémonies de vœux ces
dernières
semaines quelle inquiétude quand
j'entends que plus de la moitié des
enfants bénéficient dans des communes de
la cantine à 1 € là où le dispositif est
déployé c'est dire si la pauvreté touche
l'ensemble de notre pays cette France
appauvre elle ne peut plus se chauffer
correctement et Monsieur le Maire votre
Ministre assène qu'au nom de la
nécessaire satisfaction des agences de
notation il faut d de
augmenter de 10 % les tarifs de
l'électricité Monsieur le Premier
Ministre ouvrez les yeux au regard de la
réalité sociale du pays plus 44 %
d'augmentation en 2 ans plus 70 %
d'augmentation en 10 ans ce n'est pas
supportable le droit à l'énergie n'est
pas une question de bouclier c'est une
question de droit une question de
dignité logement nourriture soins
transport éducation
cela devient inaccessible à des millions
de personnes et se dégrade pour la
plupart monsieur le Premier ministre je
veux vous le dire le réarmement
démographique ne se décrète pas il passe
par de meilleurs salaires par une
meilleure politique familiale mais aussi
par une politique de logement de hausse
des salaires qui permettent à chacune
d'entre à chacune et à chacun d'entre
nous d'entrevoir le meilleur pour nos
enfants il passe aussi inévitablement
par une école publique de qualité
véritable lieu de savoir d'apprentissage
pour leur permettre de réussir leur vie
que répondez-vous aux enseignants qui
exigent par une grève massive demain des
moyens pour l'école publique la violente
crise agricole croise finalement toutes
les autres crises une mondialisation et
une finorisation et freiné la domination
de grands groupes qui étouff les
agriculteurs il faut simplifier repenser
l'accumulation des normes mais il faut
aussi s'attaquer au libre échange qui
promet de livrer par cargo entier de la
viande auovin de Nouvelle-Zélande ou
bine du Brésil l'urgence c'est aider les
jeunes agriculteurs avec le retour des
prêts bonifiés à l'installation le
premier volet de la loi égalime doit
être respecté et l'État doit être le
garant du respect des agriculteurs face
au requin de la grande distribution
il est inacceptable que les agriculteurs
ne puissent vivre de leur travail et que
les consommateurs ne peuvent se nourrir
correctement et Monsieur le Premier
Ministre ce n'est pas un problème de
marché mais c'est bien un enjeu et un
choix politique Monsieur le Premier
Ministre vous êtes aujourd'hui devant le
Sénat qui selon la Constitution
représente les collectivités
territoriales ces collectivités
territoriales ont été et sont la
dernière digue face à ces crises mult p
les élus et leur administration y font
face chaque jour avec des moyens
décroissants alors que la demande
explose difficulté d'accès aux soins au
logement difficulté de pouvoir d'achat
or quelle mesure apportera votre
gouvernement face à l'étranglement
financier progressif et à la perte de
l'autonomie financière des communes
allez-vous enfin indexer la DGF sur
l'inflation vous l'avez augmenté de 0,8
mais l'inflation est à 5 %. allez-vous
rétablir la CVAE pour faire participer
les acteurs économiques aux finances des
collectivités la commune monsieur le
Premier ministre c'est la proximité le
maillage étroit du territoire national
et de la démocratie menacer cette
institution clé de la République mais
plus profondément de notre société c'est
menacer l'édifice institutionnel déjà
vacillant oui renforcer la démocratie
locale et l'État territorial est une
nécessité pour construire les politiques
publiques indispensables au bienvvre de
nos concitoyens il ne peut y avoir de
décentralisation que si l'État est fort
assume ses missions régaliennes de santé
de sécurité de santé et d'aménagement du
territoire pour in égalité entre tous et
entre les territoires et Monsieur le
Premier Ministre pas d'hypocrisie entre
nous les élus locaux ne pourront pas
tout supporter la décentralisation
demain ne peut-être d'absorber les
défaillances de l'État quotidiennement
monsieur le Premier ministre le terrain
perdu que j'évoqué d'emblé c'est
évidemment celui de la démocratie votre
refus de soumettre au vote de confiance
au motif relativement absurde
permettez-moi que vous n'avez pas de
majorité accompagne de fait la main mise
totale du président de la République sur
les institutions la clé de voûe de la 5e
République ce qui en fait un régime
parlementaire c'est la responsabilité du
gouvernement devant l'Assemblée
nationale c'est j'oserai dire le ventre
de confiance originelle ce refus de vote
augure mal de la volonté de la
dénonciation du recours au 493 qui a
marqué l'année 2023 ce n'est donc plus
au Parlement que les choix politique se
décide mais dans les couloirs sur les
plateaux de télévision sur les réseaux
sociaux ou à quelques-uns en commission
mixte paritaire écoutons écoutez
Monsieur le Premier Ministre nos
concitoyens de tous les horizons
territoires ruraux urbains et
ultramarins qui font la France et sa
grandeur ceux qui souffrent et
n'obtiennent pas de réponse face à cette
politique menée depuis 2017 que vous
avez servi avec zel nous ne pouvons en
toute logique vous accordz notre
confiance mais comme vote il n'y aura
pas vous sortirez de cet exercice par
une analyse une évaluation médiatique
alors que nos concitoyens ont plus que
jamais besoin d'une analyse et d'une
évaluation démocratique merci madame la
Présidente la parole est au président
Claude maluret pour le groupe Les
[Applaudissements]
Indépendants
président merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre comme tout
chef de gouvernement vous allez
affronter de nombreux défis politiques
et le premier bien sûr est l'absence de
majorité parlementaire qui n'a permis
jusqu'à ce jour que des palliatifs
imparfaits négociation épuisantes ou 493
au goût amer le second défi est la
pression permanente et déprimante des
extrêmes la France échappe encore à la
vague de populisme qui frappe les
démocraties parce que si ailleurs le
populisme n'est que d'extrême droite
chez nous où l'on apprenda des l'école
qu'il faut préférer reespierre à
Toqueville il est coupé en deux la fin
de ces exceptions est proche parce qu'il
faisait le plus de bruit parce qu'il
avait réussi à embrigader une gauche en
perdition parce qu'il transformait
l'Assemblée en zone à délirer le danger
d'extrême gauche paraissait le plus
dangereux exacerbé par une caisse de
résonance médiatique qui confirme que
rien n'est plus sonore que ce qui est
creux mais la nupèe attelage improbable
de la gauche W de la gauche velllibe de
la gauche caviar de la gauche
stalinienne de la gauche trotskiste et
de la gauche Hamas s'est effondraé sous
le poids de ses incohérences le tegevara
des calan en cédant la direction des
insoumis et la présidence du groupe
parlementaire à des comparses choisit
tous deux non pas malgré mais en raison
de leurs insuffisances a compris
tardivement qu'il avait pris le train
dans la mauvaise direction il court
depuis en sens inverse dans le couloir à
grand geste des bras et du menton
lançant ses imprécations aux alliés
comme aux ennemis mais ne parvenant qu'à
démontrer que sa vie est devenue une
interminable rage de dents
fit c'était une surprise partie la
surprise c'est qu'il n'y avait pas de
parti pas de statut pas de vote pas
d'élection juste une secte gérée par un
couple omnipotent comme les Ténardiers
tenaient le bouche de
Montfermeil le mouvement s'est fait à
rakiri le 7 octobre avec l'ignominie de
trop le refus de condamner le massacre
du Hamas qualifié de mouvement de
résistance les partenaires enrôlés dans
cette pantalonnade on on profiter pour
filer à l'anglaise après que tout le
monde a
dessoulé ils resteront ceux qui ont
bradé à un emprenti dictateur les
valeurs de la gauche qu'ils ont fracturé
pour un plat de lentille
électoral cet échec n'est pas qu'une
bonne nouvelle le danger s'est déplacé
dans une extrême droite qui se renforce
en proportion du déclin de son rival
porosité qui prouve que ce qui les
rapproche est infiniment plus fort que
ce qui les sépare comme Orban est devenu
l'habit de Poutine comme l'extrême
gauche italienne vote pour mélonie le RN
fait ses meilleurs scores aussi bien
dans les ass bastions du PC que dans
ceux de la droite les gauchistes sont
bruyants débraillés et réclament tout
tout de suite les marinistes sont
silencieux cravaté et attendent leur
heure ils savent que face aux insoumis
il suffit de se taire pour paraître
intelligent ils n'ont aucun programme
ils affichent des convictions absolues
mais si ils n'ont aucun problèmme pour
en changer si elles ne vous plaisent pas
comme sur la sortie de l'euro ou le
frxit ils affirment que nous dansons sur
le pont du Titanic mais c'est eux
l'iceberg ils ont enforché tous les
délires complletistes ils ont été
antivax VRP de
l'hydroxychlorokine ils font aujourd'hui
le sale boulot de chien garde de Poutine
et ils le font salement ce qui n'est pas
étonnant dans ce pays fondé largement
par d'anciens collabo il dénonce la
corruption des mais leurs parlementaires
européens sont mis en examen pour avoir
détourné des millions d'euros ce parti
opaque est une sorte de traboule ces
arrière cours obscur des immeubles
Lyonnais à la façade bien propre les
anciens du Gude sont toujours là dans
l'ombre les contrats sistent anonymisé
sur les réseaux sociaux aussi enfin les
deux campagnes présidentielles de marine
Poutine arrivé à son poste comme Kim
jongun par népotisme ont fourni la
preuve de sa parfaite inaptitude à la
fonction et pourtant le reflux du
populisme d'extrême gauche lui ouvre un
boulevard la photo en 2027 d'un Emmanuel
Macron raccompagné par elle sur le Peron
de l'Élysée comme Obama avait cédé sa
place à Trump n'est plus un
vraisemblable la fonction que vous
exercez aujourd'hui Monsieur le Premier
Ministre vous a été confiée aussi pour
faire obstacle à cette hypothèse lugue à
cela il y a deux conditions la première
est de réussir les 12 travaux d'hercu
qui vous attendre dans un pays tarodé
depuis toujours c'est sa grande
faiblesse par le doute la hantise du
déclin et le pessimisme relever le
niveau de l'école guérir le système de
santé redonner l'espoir aux agriculteurs
poursuivre la baisse du chômage
réindustrialiser le pays réduire le
déficit construire l'Europe puissance
réformer l'État er l'autorité au sein de
la société maîtriser l'immigration
assurer le développement durable à la
française je n'insiste pas vous-même et
tous les orateurs précédents avaient
détaillé ce constat la tâche est immense
je n'ai énuméré que 11 travaux le 12e
est capital mais le moins compris le
chef de l'État a évoqué le réarmement
moral économique civique il reste le
réarmement au sens propre nous sommes en
guerre
c'est une très mauvaise idée européenne
d'affirmer chaque jour qu'on veut pas la
guerre qu'on n'est pas en guerre lorsque
vos ennemis le sont l'international des
dictateurs ne s'en cache pas Russie
Chine Iran Corée du
Nord procl qu'ils veulent abattre l'OTAN
l'Europe et l'Occident et ils font ce
qu'ils disent la guerre en Ukraine se
voit à cause des tans et des missiles
cell qu'il nous livre cyberataque
désinformation
milliers de comptes sur les réseaux
antisociaux pour fusser les élections
abrutissement de nos enfants sur TikTok
pendant que la Chine protège les siens
et tout aussi violent elle mine nos
démocraties de l'intérieur la Russie
s'est mise en économie de guerre notre
président parle d'économie de guerre
mais aucun pays d'Europe n'est capable 2
ans après le 24 février de livrer à
l'Ukraine ne serait-ce que les munitions
promises si l'Ukraine perd la guerre
c'est l'Europe qui la per
par peur d'annoncer les mauvaises
nouvelles les gouvernements
démocratiques ne préparent pas leurs
opinions publiques à cette réalité
lorsque j'écoute certains d'entre eux
j'ai l'impression d'entendre le toctc du
parapluie de Dadier sur les pavés de
Munich Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous
serez certes jugé sur vos résultats dans
notre pays mais à l'échelle de
l'histoire votre gouvernement et tous
les gouvernements d'Europe seront jugés
à l'ône de la victoire ou de la défaite
des démocraties face à l'international
reconstitué des dictateur la deuxième
condition pour qu'en 2027 au soir de
l'élection présidentielle le visage qui
paraît sur nos écrans à 20h ne soit pas
celui qui comme ceux de Trump d'Orban ou
de bolsonaro nous fasse honte ne dépend
pas seulement de vous il est grand temps
que ceux qui se revendiquent du camp de
la raison comprennent que le temps leur
est compté s'ils ne sont pas capables de
s'unir face à des extrêmes qui nagent
comme des poissons dans l'eau des raisau
antisociaux des fake new et de l'injure
il ne faudra pas qu'ils se plaignne
d'une défaite qu'ils n'auront su
empêcher il est temps que les
raisonnables se rassemblent qu'ils
construissent une majorité ou des
alliances seule façon de gouverner la
France avec succès ce souhait sera
peut-être aujourd'hui considéré avec
indifférence ou avec ironie mais dans
quelques mois lorsque ça'affichera le
résultat des élections européennes ce
qui dans la majorité comme dans les
oppositions républicaines se plaise dans
des curelles de cours d'école
comprendront je l'espère que le temps
des anathèmes est terminé le général
MacArthur disait que les batailles
perdues se résument en deux mots trop
tard réfléchissons à cette phrase tant
qu'il est encore temps je vous
remercie
merci monsie le
président la parole est maintenant
madame la Présidente Mar pour le
remblementmocque social
européen
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues si nous avons tous ici un
devoir de vérité sur la situation de la
France nous avons aussi celui de
cultiver l'espoir par nos initiatives et
le dialogue avec nos territoires il
revient à chacun d'entre nous quel que
soient nos sensibilités ou nos
désaccords de faire preuve de
responsabilité et de courage pour
réparer enrichir et préserver notre
modèle social et républicain sans
méconnaître les difficultés que
rencontre notre pays versé dans le
pessimisme ou la nostalgie d'une douce
France a jamais disparu ce n'est ni
responsable ni mobilisateur sans tout
promettre nous devons néanmoins trouver
les voies pour que oui Monsieur le
Premier Ministre nos enfants vivent
mieux demain que nous ne vivons
aujourd'hui un nouveau cap pour l'emploi
l'éducation la santé le logement la
sécurité le RDSE est prêt à entendre les
nouvelles propositions à les débattre à
soutenir toutes celles qui
s'inscriraient sans détour dans le
sillon de la justice sociale de la
solidarité et du progrès vous nous
trouverez à vos côtés sur le chemin
d'une école qui tiendrait mieux son rôle
si toutefois l'uniforme n'est pas un
cache misère mais bien le signal d'un
retour au fondamentaux de l'école
républicaine au premier rang desquels
l'égalité des chances vous le savez mon
groupe est également attaché aux
manifestations de l'appartenance
républicaine et au respect du principe
de laïcité nous espérons la continuité
d'une certaine fermeté que vous avez
démontré sur la laïcité Monsieur le
Premier Ministre indispensable pour
protéger les consciences en éveil et
encourager l'esprit de tolérance chez
les jeunes condition du vivre ensemble
mon groupe est également attaché à une
citoyenneté réarmée pour employer vos
mots nous avons porté au débat du Sénat
a des propositions que vous qu'on vous
demande de regarder nous serons
également au rendez-vous de l'écologie
comme nous l'avons toujours été pourvu
que celle-ci ne soit pas punitive mais
plutôt intelligente cohérente et
soutenable par les forces vives de
l'économie ainsi que par les plus
modestes le dérèglement climatique
nécessite une large planification des
réflexions transversales et beaucoup
d'innovations pour atteindre ses
objectifs c'est sûrement l'un des défis
les plus difficiles la crise avec le
monde agricole en est l'illustration le
RDSE a toujours défendu une agriculture
durable mais pas au prix du sacrifice de
milliers d'exploitants car c'est bien
cela qui se joue ils vous le disent
partout dans l'Hexagone et depuis
quelques jours dans les outrmers ils se
meurent quand ils ne meurent pas au sens
propre trop de normes une concurrence
étrangère déloyale la pression des
distributeurs et au bout de la haie
d'obstacle des revenus indécents alors
oui nous comprenons leur colère et nous
serons attentifs aux solutions proposées
il est d'ailleurs bien regrettable que
le travail de contrôle des
parlementaires ne soit pas davantage
regardé en l'espèce les 63 propositions
du rapport sur la détresse des
agriculteurs et bien sûr à quand et un
véritable partage de la valeur sur le
front de l'emploi vous annoncez un acte
2 difficile de dire à cette heure si
vous parviendrez à atteindre votre
objectif de plein emploi dans un
contexte économique mondiale fragile on
ne peut que le souhaiter dynamiser le
dialogue de branche baisser les charges
expérimenter la semaine de 4 jours dans
l'administration nous regarderons avec
intérêt et vigilance tous ces projets
rendre la lumière aux travailleurs de
l'ombre dans les bureaux du secteur
public est une belle mesure et nous la
saluons il faudra pousser sûrement
jusqu'au privé sur les conditions de
travail lors de l'examen de la réforme
des retraites mon groupe a souhaité sans
être être toujours entendu des mesures
fortes concernant la pénibilité Monsieur
le Premier Ministre soyez rapidement au
rendez-vous de tout ce qui constitue la
contrepartie légitime du recul de l'âge
de départ à la retraite sans attendre
aussi il faut renforcer et non colmater
notre système de santé au fil des
décennies il se fracture un peu plus
avec un point d'orgue les déserts
médicaux quel moyen supplémentaire il en
faudra nous sommes en tout cas heureux
que notre résolution sur la santé
mentale des jeunes adoptés en début
d'année trouve déjà un écho auprès du
gouvernement comment aussi espérer le
réarmement démographique promu par le
chef de l'État quand le secteur
périnatal est en danger mon groupe s'en
empare cette année par une mission
d'information sans logement pas de
projets parentaux non plus en France en
2024 des travailleurs vivent dans leur
voitures dans les grandes villes des
sans abriis dorment sous les fenêtres
des Airbnb c'est intolérable comment ne
pas vous suivre quand vous dites vouloir
construire plus de logements et
simplifier les procédures évidemment on
ne peut pas ignorer le coût du
renforcement de toutes ces politiques
publiques aussi je m'inquiète des cibles
qui feront les frais de 12000 des 12
milliards d'économies promis pour l'an
prochain alors que beaucoup de nos
services publics sont en difficulté nous
partageons évidemment votre objectif de
redressement des comptes publics mais
nous savons aussi que la la question
cruciale est celle du rythme de cet
ajustement s'il est trop rapide il
pèsera sur la croissance française et
cela et cela ne fera qu'aggraver notre
dette soyez mesurés je rappellerai que
le dernier défaut de paiement de la
France date de
1787 mais j'entends bien aussi ce que
l'Europe vous commande et nous commande
oorddse nous l'pportons dans notre titre
car nous la portons dans notre cœur mais
ce n'est pas un amour inconditionnel
nous l'avons démontré en faisant adopter
dès 2018 une résolution sur le
Mercosur malgré ses imperfections
l'Union européenne n'est pas un problème
elle est bien souvent la solution et
vous avez rappelé Monsieur le Premier
Ministre toutes les digues qu'elle a su
construire pour protéger nos concitoyens
ils ne doivent pas l'oublier et ne pas
céder aux sirènes des populismes qui se
résume bien souvent bien souvent à la
peur de l'autre un remanimement c'est
redonner un cap ce endant on ne tient
pas seul un gouvernail en cas de fortte
tempête mieux vaut s'appuyer sur les
loups de mer personne ne doute je crois
Monsieur le Premier Ministre de votre
lucidité de votre volontarisme mais les
réponses vous le savez viendront aussi
des territoire des corps intermédiaires
du monde associatif et de tous les élus
locaux sans lesquels rien ne serait
possible des élus locaux mieux protégés
en sécurité eux aussi libérés du poids
des normes pour mieux exercer leur
mission un nouvel acte de la
décentralisation pourquoi pas si cela
consiste à redonner du souffle aux
collectivité local pour qu'elles
reprennent en main leur destin dans
plusieurs domaines et je citerai la
compétence haut et assaainissement que
nous avons défendu ici à travers notre
proposition de loi l'intelligence des
territoires en tant que sénateur nous
sommes là pour la faire remonter dans
l'hémicycle et à à disposition du
gouvernement aussi pour terminer
permettez-moi Monsieur le Premier
Ministre d'espérer que vous trouviez la
bonne méthode que vous puissiez réussir
et ne pas décevoir vous le devez à la
jeunesse française dans sa diversité
avec laquelle vous partagez sans doute
l'audace mais pour faire remonter la
France sur le podium sans blessure
n'oubliez pas le vivier de l'expérience
je vous remercie merci madame la
Présidente la parole est maintenant au
président Guillaume Gard pour le groupe
écologie solidarité
territoire
la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier ministre depuis 7
ans Emmanuel Macron s'efforce à
contettemps d'imposer à la France la mer
potion néolibérale des années 80 depuis
7 ans à part pour signer des cheèqus en
blanc aux entreprises vous combattez la
dépense publique appauvrisser les
collectivités locales déplumer l'État et
amputer les services publics depuis 7
ans vous avez enrichi les plus riches
abîmé les mécanismes de redistribution
amoindri les filets de protection
sociale et fait exploser les inégalités
vous nous annoncez la poursuite de cette
politique de casse sociale sans
précédent en vous attaquant au salaire
minimum au minimas sociaux et en
détricotant la loi et SRU un premier
ministre du 7e arrondissement de Paris
et l'exécutant zellé du président des
riches tout cela coule malheureusement
de source cependant nous n'avions pas
anticipé que le plus jeune président et
le plus plus jeune premier ministre de
la 5e République soit à ce point non pas
conservateur mais réactionnaire la
demeure l'imposture originelle du
macronisme qui s'était d'abord présenté
comme un libéralisme chimiquement pur à
l'anglo-saxon et qui est aujourd'hui un
trumpisme élégant de Rotary Club la
pandémie mondiale la guerre en Ukraine
et la crise écologique ont achevé de
démontrer l'impasse de la mondialisation
et de votre dogmatisme néolibéral or
sans lui vous n'avez aucun cap vous vous
contentez de gérer les crises toujours
de la même manière réactionnaire
autoritaire et depuis peu populiste
Emmanuel Macron devrait permettre à
chacun de vivre de son travail 7 ans
plus tard les agriculteurs bloquent le
pays étouffés par la concurrence
mondiale déloyale et la rapacité de la
grande distribution face à une crise
structurelle dont votre idéologie est la
cause fondamentale vous vous engouffrez
dans une dérive populiste qui fait de la
protection de l'environnement et de la
biodiversité l'épouvantail des
difficultés du monde agricole vos
premières mesure n'apporte aucune
réponse pour garantir un revenu décent
aux hommes et aux femmes qui nourrissent
la France ou pour renforcer notre
souveraineté alimentaire
vous gardez bien de combattre le libre
échange de réinstaurer des quotas ou de
répondre ou de refondre pardon une pâqu
qui engresse surtout quelques
privilégiés vous n'avez rien fait pour
rehausser les salaires renforcer le
pouvoir d'achat des Français et des
Français et leur permettre notamment de
se nourrir correctement avec des
produits locaux et de qualité c'est
pourtant une des condition syinequanon
de la rémunération décente de nos
agriculteurs rien non plus pour
favoriser l'installation et la
transmission qui passera par une
indispensable réorganisation du travail
Emmanuel Macron avait en 2017 une
certaine vision des évolutions du
travail 7 ans plus tard cette vision
s'est perdue dans le costume gris d'un
comptable triste vous ne considérez le
travail que comme un coût en refusant
d'indexer les salaires sur l'inflation
en ne revalorisant pas les
fonctionnaires en reculant l'âge de la
retraite vous dévalorisez le travail
tout en prétendant réhabiliter la valeur
travail cherchez l'erreur Emmanuel
Macron devrait être le président du
renouveau démocratique 7 ans plus tard
faute de pouvoir se nommer lui-même il
nomme un Premier ministre qui ne
sollicite même pas la confiance du
Parlement aucun pouvoir républicain n'a
gouverné de manière a aussi centralisé
aussi autoritaire avec un tel méprisu du
peuple et de tous les corps
intermédiaires voilà votre réponse à la
crise des gilets jaunes dont les
doléances sont encore sous Cellé
Emmanuel Macron promettait une
République exemplaire 7 ans plus tard on
ne remanie plus pour exfiltrer mais pour
faire entrer au gouvernement des
ministres mis en examen
Emmanuel Macron avait fait de
l'éducation et de la culture son premier
chantier 7 ans plus tard vous faites
vous-même le terrible le constat de la
crise du métier de professeur et vous
n'annoncez rien pour revaloriser pire
vous déployez des écrans de fumée sur
laaba vous vous égosillez sur la licité
à l'école tout en laissant prospérer le
séparatisme scolaire de l'enseignement
privé catholique vous en faites presque
un modèle pour l'école publique en
revenant sur les acquis de Mai 68 à coup
d'uniforme obligatoire de respect de
l'autorité et de service universel ou
CIVI action réaction nous voici revenus
au modèle rééducatif du tyragnique
directeur Rachin dans les coristes
l'éducation punitive voilà votre réponse
à la nouvelle crise des banlieu qui a
agité notre pays l'été dernier voilà
votre réponse à notre jeunesse enquête
de sens dans le vieux monde qui se mort
terisé théorisé par gramchi ce n'est
même pas une politique de boomer c'est
une politique d'avant-guerre la jeunesse
de ce pays et de ce continent se demande
dans quel monde elle vivra et vous ne
faites pas le lien avec la baisse de la
natalité déconn
le président de la République dans un
discours que le croirit sorti du
lendemain de la Grande Guerre appelle à
réarmer démographiquement la France
sous-entendu pour faire des soldats et
des cotisants pour notre régime de
retraite vous annoncez que la santé
mentale de la jeunesse sera votre grande
cause nationale on pourrait saluer
l'initiative si la précédente grande
cause ne s'était pas achevée en un
soutien abject à Gérard parieux Emmanuel
grron devait être le barrage à l'extrême
droite ans plus tard il a ouvert toutes
les vannes la loi immigration demeurera
comme une indélébile déchéance politique
et
morale avant de vous présenter devant le
Parlement vous avez soigneusement
attendu un mois la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel sur laquelle vous
comptiez pour censurer les pires
atrocités de votre pacte faustien avec
la droite extrême et l'extrême droite
mais personne n'est dupe le même
ministre de l'Intérieur incarnant votre
dérive illibérale si toujours à vos
côtés et votre pacte de gouvernement
tacite avec les soi-disants républicains
demeure mes chers collègues de droite je
vous le dis gravement vous avez depuis
plusieurs semaines critiqué la
constitution du général de Gaulle avec
la même virulence que les héritiers de
Pétin vous êtes sur une pente glissante
qui vous mène hors du champ républicain
si vous refusez de l'entendre de ma
bouche entendez-le de celle de Xavier
Bertrand monsieur le Premier ministre je
n'ai pas encore parlé écologie du moins
dans la conception encilotée que vous
vous en faites mais tout ce que je viens
d'évoquer le renforcement du pouvoir de
vivre la réorganisation du travail le
renouveau démocratique le renforcement
des libertés publiques et de l'État de
droit un regard ouvert et accueillant
sur le reste de l'humanité un projet
éducatif qui fait confiance en notre
jeunesse un projet pour lui redonner
espoir dans l'avenir c'est ça l'écologie
l'écologie est la vision qui vous manque
pour à partir des territoires et de
l'innovation locale recréer de
l'activité économique et recouvrer notre
souveraineté grâce à une transition
agricole pourvoyeuse d'emploi et
rémunératrice pour les producteurs grâce
à une réindustrialisation vertueuse
concentrée sur nos besoins essentiels et
pensé d'une dans une logique circulaire
grâce à la transition énergétique plus
compétitive et plus souveraine que le
nucléaire grâce encore à une production
de logements biosourcés économ en
énergie et reposant sur des filières
locales l'écologie est la solution pour
résorber la fracture territoriale en
repensant les mobilités l'urbanisme et
en permettant à celles et ceux qui le
souhaitent de quitter les métropoles
l'écologie est la solution pour
contrôler notre dépense publique grâce à
des investissements intelligents et à la
séobriété l'écologie est à elle seule
une politique de santé publique
l'écologie est la solution pour enfin
dépasser nos divisions nos haines nos
égoïsmes et se Mobil
ensemble dans un objectif qui concerne
l'avenir de l'humanité tout entière
l'écologie et la solution
merci merci la parole est pour la
Réunion administrative des sénateurs
n'appartenant à aucun groupe à notre
collègue josois
auchochard il a 3
minutes sur
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues monsieur
le Premier ministre vous avez fait une
déclaration de politique générale qui a
surjoulé le volontarisme drappé dans la
nouveauté qu'inspire votre nomination
récente vous semblez découvrir une
situation dans laquelle ni vous ni
Emmanuel Macron n'auriez aucune
responsabilité un bilan dont vous ne
seriez pas comptable ainsi sous couvert
de modernité de jeunesse votre logiciel
politique est daté obsolète voilà que la
crise agricole lancinante et menaçante
depuis des décennies vous saute à la
figure les ravage du libre échange d'une
politique bruxelloise déconnectée des
réalités du monde paysan d'un
gouvernement rester sourd au cris de
colère et de désespoir tous ces mots que
le rassemblement national dénonce depuis
longtemps vous semblez les découvrir
aujourd'hui alors que nos agriculteurs
convergent vers Paris dans un mouvement
pacifique et pleinement soutenu par les
Français Monsieur le Premier Ministre
tous ceux qui ont échoué depuis 10 ans
de gauche comme de droite vous les avez
soutenu d'une manière ou d'une autre
vous avez été incapable par idéologie et
par conformisme de résister à un libre
échange délirant comment peut-on encore
vous croire en sachant que la feuille de
route ultralibérale continuera à être
déroulée dans les Mo les années à venir
comment pour pourrez-vous rétablir la la
confiance alors que vous êtes comptable
d'aucun dirait coupable du malheur de
nos paysans Monsieur le Premier Ministre
vous parlez d'action vous accumulez les
déplacements mais vous ne pouvez rien
faire parce que vous ne vous vous lbrez
pas d're entrave confortable d'entrave
qui permettent de systématiquement
rejeter la responsabilité des échecs
c'est à Bruxelles que se dessine notre
politique agricole et c'est là tout le
problème français le pouvoir politique
n'existe plus il est dilué abandonné par
les politiques eux-mêmes et nos
compatriotes l'ont bien compris
Bruxelles décideent et les Français
subissent c'est là c'est ce qui
caractérise aujourd'hui le système dont
vous êtes tenant c'est l'impuissance
qu'onenti à ce titre comment ne pas
revenir sur la question sécuritaire et
migratoire sur la poursuite en 2023 de
l'immigration massive sur la
nonexécution des qtf avec leur lot de
drame sur les émeutes qui ont enflammé
le pays en juillet Monsieur le Premier
Ministre vous évoquez hier à juste titre
votre satisfaction de pouvoir être
Premier ministre et homosexuel assumé en
2024 monsieur le Premier ministre
permettez-moi de sortir de l'immédiateté
et de vous poser une question si le
laxisme sécuritaire immigratoire perdure
pensez-vous que nous pourrons encore
assumer notre homosexualité en 2034 je
l'espère et cette question me permet de
soulever le drame de nos compatriotes
qui s'aggrave chaque année un peu plus 7
ans de naronie c'est 7 ans de précarité
c'est 7 ans d'incapacité pour nos
compatriotes à se projeter à faire des
sacrifices et des compromis parce que
leur pouvoir d'achat est laassite de
mesquinerie permanente et l'exécutoire
du quoi qu'il en coûte Monsieur le
Premier Ministre vous nous avez fait
l'image hier d'une France idéale mais
être français en 2024 c'est aussi avoir
du mal à boucler ses fins de mois et
quelquefois même les débuts de mois être
français en 2024 c'est une pas trouver
de place dans un dans un institut
spécialisé pour y placer son enfant en
situation de handicap vos promesses
monsieur le Premier ministre n'y
changeront rien votre communication
léchée ne nous fera pas oublier la
réalité et votre bilan votre
gouvernement demeure minoritaire dans
les chambre comme dans le pays Monsieur
le Premier Ministre prenons date et dans
6 mois 1 an 2 ans nous faisons le pari
que rien n'aura changé les Français
veulent des acteurs au quotidien pas les
témoins du déclin je vous remercie merci
la monsieur le Premier
ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs je
veux remercier l'ensemble des orateurs
qui se sont exprimés et qui ont je le
crois tous été dans une
logique constructive je l'espère en tout
cas tourner vers l'intérêt général des
Français et et l'intérêt de notre pays
peut-être revenir sur quelques points
qui ont été euh
aborder je vous ai entendu monsieur
retaillot insister sur la nécessité que
nous avons de continuer à agir pour le
réarmement économique de notre pays et
qu'on soit bien clair je ne crois pas
avoir donné le sentiment tout à l'heure
ou avoir donné ce sentiment hier ou dans
mes différentes interventions que je
considère que tout va mieux dans le
meilleur des mondes en France pas du
tout simplement je pense que quand ça
correspond à une réalité je pense et par
ailleurs que c'est ma responsabilité
c'est bien de dire quand il y a des
choses qui s'améliorent et la réalité
c'est que nous sommes de point en
dessous du niveau de chômage que nous
connaissions en 2017 il n pas été aussi
bas depuis 25 ans il y a 2 millions
d'emplois qui ont été créés dans notre
pays c'est un succès je vais vous dire
que je ne mets même pas nécessairement
au crédit ou je ne dis pas que c'est le
succès avant tout du gouvernement c'est
un succès collectif de notre pays qui a
réussi à créer des emplois nos
entreprises qui créent quand même elles
les emplois on les a accompagné on les a
soutenu mais c'est surtout un succès
pour ces millions de familles qui ont pu
retrouver un emploi et qui peuvent vivre
dans la dignité et donc moi je ne suis
pas là à dire que tout est rose
évidemment simplement je pense qu'on
peut tous s'accorder sur le fait que
tout n'est pas noir voilà et qu'il y a
probablement une réalité entre les deux
vous avez fait la comparaison avec
l'Allemagne c'est vrai que nous sommes
encore nettement au-dessus des Allemands
s'agissant du taux de chômage et par
ailleurs nettement a-dessus des allemand
s'agissant du déficit et de la dette on
peut aussi regarder une situation
économique aujourd'hui qui est plus
dynamique qu'en Allemagne quand on se
compare entre les deux ce qui n'est pas
nécessairement d'ailleurs une bonne
nouvelle pour nous d'avoir une Allemagne
en récession parce que ça a un impact
immédiat sur notre sur notre PIB mais
évidemment on va poursuivre on va
poursuivre les efforts
sur la la question de nos agriculteurs
moi je l'ai dit il faut tenir et nous
tiendrons cet engagement clair pas de de
surtransposition et pas d'interdiction
sans solution ensuite vous abordez la
question de surtransposition existante
entre guillemets il y en a beaucoup
moins qu'avant puisqu'il y a un certain
nombre de de molécules pour lesquel
notre pays avait fait le choix avant
2017 de les interdire mais les pays
européens ont ensuite rejoint la marche
donc je pense que le sujet vaut avant
tout pour l'avenir même si je suis très
vigilant et notamment à des situations
vous avez des molécules qui sont
interdites en Europe mais Don
l'interdiction est manifestement
contournée dans dans certains pays qui
nous entourent qui sont peut-être moins
tillons que nous sur les contrôles et
donc c'est ça je pense que qui doit nous
animer aussi ensuite j'assume de le dire
quand nous avons une agence sanitaire
française indépendante donc je respecte
évidemment le travail mais qui de son
initiative prend une décision
d'interdiction d'un produit alors même
que le régulateur européen est en train
de se pencher sur l'interdiction de ce
produit je trouve que ça pose un
problème et qu'on doit probablement
revoir l'organisation pour que le
régulateur européen et les régulateurs
nationaux puissent parler de concert
sinon effectivement on met nos
agriculteurs dans une situation de
concurrence déloyal donc sur tous ces
sujets on va continuer à avancer dans
les prochaines heures on en parle tous
les jours matin midi et soir avec les
représentants des agriculteurs je veux
revenir sur ce que vous avez dit sur mon
gouvernement moi je crois au dépassement
politique et au rassemblement c'est pour
ça que j'ai rejoint Emmanuel Macron en
2017 je crois par ailleurs qu'il y a eu
d'autres moments dans l'histoire compris
avec des présidents pas si lointain ça
s'appelait l'ouverture mais en tout cas
il y avait des personnalités politiques
qui venaient d'autres formations mais
surtout surtout moi ce qui m'a convaincu
en
2017 que mettre autour de la table des
femmes des hommes qui viennent
d'horizons politique ou de partis
politiques différents pour les faire
travailler ensemble c'est pas l'exemple
des gouvernements Fillon ou autres c'est
mon expérience de conseiller municipal
parce que s'il y a
une assemblée en France où on est
capable de se dire on n'est pas du même
parti on est parfois pas de la même
liste mais on peut avancer ensemble sur
certains sujets voire même d'ailleurs
avant les majorités opposition et puis à
l'élection suivante bah on revoit le
périmètre de la liste et la majorité on
intgre des personnes qui étaient
auparavant dans l'opposition c'est dans
nos assemblées communales et donc je
crois profondément que ici au Sénat on
peut justement comprendre qu'on puisse
sur un certain nombre de projets voire
même pour rejoindre une majorité
s'accorder entre des des personnes qui
viennent d'horizons différents c'est
vrai c'est très juste vous avez raison
monsieur le rapporteur je veux revenir
rapidement sur l'intervention de
François patria et le remercier d'avoir
mis en avant deux enjeux absolument
majeurs celui de nos outremèes et de
notre rualité qui ont absolument besoin
d'un investissement particulier j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire dans mon
intervention tout à l'heure évidemment
on va continuer à avancer sur la
question de la ruralité je veux revenir
sur le choix qui a été fait d'avoir des
stratégies beaucoup plus proches de
chacun de nos territoires c'est les
pactes régionaux dans la Creuse les
pactes territoriaux dans la Creuse dans
la niève dans les Ardennes dans le
sravenois tierarche c'est le sens du
plan Marseille en grand al ça c'est pas
la ruralité mais c'est la mais c'est la
territorialisation c'est la
territorialisation c'est pour ça qu'on
continue à agir je le disais tout à
l'heure pour la ruralité sur ce coupci
en doublant la dotation d'aménité rurale
qu'on a pérénisé les zones de
revitalisation rurale que pour les
centes-villees qui parfois se meurent on
a lancé je le disais tout à l'heure
action cœur de ville pour plus de 200
communes qu'on a lancé petite ville de
demain pour aller aider au développement
de plus de 1600 communes quand je me
déplace et que je me rends dans des
collectivités des communes qui ont
bénéficié de ces programmes je vois tout
ce que ça a apporté à ces territoires
notamment ruraux évidemment on va
poursuivre l'investissement sur les
maisons France servic sur l'attention
qu'on porte à l'accès au services public
dans la ruralité avec les médicobus
les budgets que nous déployons pour le
commerce dans nos départements ruraux je
veux revenir sur l'intervention de
Madame carer et notamment sur un point
de votre intervention sur la question
des fins de carrière en lien avec la
réforme des retraites et sur la question
de la pénbilité c'est évidemment un
enjeu majeur je serais très attentif à
ce que les budgets qui avaient été
définis dans le cadre de la réforme des
retraites juste justement pour prévenir
la pénibilité puisse être effectivement
et soit effectivement utilisé pour
prévenir cette pénibilité que ce soit
dans l'entreprise ou dans nos service
public et notamment à l'hôpital par
exemple ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que les partenaires
sociaux négocient en ce
moment sur le sujet de l'usure
professionnelle de l'emploi des seniors
et de la reconversion et que j'attends
beaucoup de cette négociation et des
propositions qui pourront intervenir sur
ce sujet qui est majeur vous l'avez dit
on a reculé l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite et on l'assume totalement mais
évidemment que ça doit nous pousser à en
faire encore davantage sur la question
de la pénibilité et de l'usure
professionnelle la reconversion de nos
seniors encore une fois merci à toutes
et à tous pour vos interventions je
remercie évidemment les interventions
constructives du président Marseille du
président maluray également je remercie
encore une fois chacune et chacun pour
leurs expressions euh et je vous dis à
bientôt avec mon gouver
jets merci monsieur le Premier
ministre mes chers collèg je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
17h45 pour la suite de la discussion de
la proposition de loi portant mesure
pour bâtir la société du Bien vieillir
en France la séance est
suspendu et voilà
donc tion de politique générale de
Gabriel hatal suivi du débat avec les
interventions successives des présidents
de groupe est terminé une réponse de
Gabriel hatal qui a duré 7 8 minutes
exactement comme hier à l'Assemblée
nationale on va d'ailleurs un petit peu
jouer au jeu des cette différence avec
son discours d'hier à l'Assemblée on va
rejoindre Quentin Calmet qui se trouve
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat fidèle au
poste Quentin vous avez tout écouté du
discours du premier ministre quand
retenez-vous qu'est-ce qu'il il y avait
aussi de spécifiques au Sénat tout à
l'heure bah ce qu'on a noté évidemment
Tam ce sont les premières déclarations
de Gabriel hatal au début de sa
politique générale pour adresser un
message au Sénat au cours de ce discours
solennel il a fait cette phras il a eu
cette phrase pour commencer le Sénat et
la chambre de la réflexion et du long
terme il est la voie des territoires et
des élus une manière dès le départ de
brosser dans le sens du poil le Sénat et
à plusieurs reprises Gabriel hatal a
fait des dédicaces à certains sénateurs
par exemple en reprenant l'idée de faire
de la santé mentale des jeunes une
grande cause du gouvernement une grande
cause nationale là il a cité la
centriste la RDSE Nathalie de lâre ou
encore à propos du soutien aux aesh il a
cité le sénateur LR Cédric Vial mais sur
le fond pas d'annonce nouvelle TH et un
discours similaire à celui d'hier avec
cette priorité je cite le premier de mes
combats restera celui du travaille
a dit Gabriel àal avec l'idée d'aller
plus loin dans la réforme de l'assurance
chômage pour je cite encore supprimer
les trappes à inactivité et le Premier
ministre de décliner trois thèmes la
désmicardisation le fait de
déverrouiller le fait de
débureaucratiser avec un exemple la fin
des surtranspositions des normes
européennes autrees sujets les
agressions des élus sur le zan le zéro
artificialisation net des sols des
sujets qui tiennent beaucoup aux
sénateurs qui tiennent beaucoup aux élus
locaux pas d'annonce mais et bien l'idée
qu'il all avancer rapidement sur ces
sujets voilà Tam pour les priorités
comme cela fixé par Gabriel Atal merci
merci beaucoup Quentin pour toutes ces
explications et première réaction j'ai
le plaisir d'accueillir le président du
groupe LR au Sénat Bruno retaillo
bonsoir bonsoir à vous Bruno retaillo
tout d'abord un mot alors que et bien ce
discours s'inscrit dans une grave crise
agricole on a entendu he le discours de
Gabrielle Atal qui a commencé par les
agriculteurs et qui a encore terminé par
les agriculteurs est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que ce discours est à même
de résoudre la crise dans laquelle nous
sommes aujourd'hui pour l'instant les
solutions n'ont pas été à la hauteur la
preuve c'est que il y a de plus en plus
de tension qui a de plus en plus de
mécontentement à tel point que les
acculteurs convergent sur Paris je pense
que ce qui manque au premier ministre
c'est justement l'ambition de changer
vraiment les choses quelques mesures
quelques ajustements peuvent pas faire
une vision ne peuvent pas faire une
politique et si on doit vraiment
apporter une solution pour les
agriculteurs il faut un arrêter sur
transposer mais maintenant c'est-à-dire
faire en sorte que les molécules par
exemple qui sont autorisées partout en
Europe sauf en France puissent être
autorisé en France ou alors on arrive à
l'interdiction partout en Europe mais
pas de concurrence déloyale deuxè chose
on'est pas là avec ce que nous annoncons
non la preuve moi je lui ai demandé déjà
il a la capacité ça ne dépend que de lui
avec un décret il prend un décret il
réajuste les choses première chose et
deuxième chose là aussi la
simplification on interdit aujourd'hui à
nos agriculteurs de s'adapter au
changement climatique pourquoi parce que
on leur met des obstacles quand ils
veulent faire des réserves de
substitution quand ils veulent stocker
l'eau or aujourd'hui il y a besoin de
stocker l'eau notamment quand il pleut
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup il pleut pas
moins il pleut de façon décalée par
exemple l'iver et restituer au milieu
mais aussi surtout pour les cultures
l'été c'est ça c'est très concret le
mercosour aussi le CTA voyez ils l'ont
accepté nous l'avons toujours refusé au
Sénat et total jamais le CTA qui est le
traité de libre échange avec le Canada
n'a été soumis au vote du du Sénat vous
ne vous retrouvez en rien dans le
discours de Gabriel Atal il a encore
répété son triptique desmicardisé
déverrouillé débureaucratisé on sait que
certains chez LR ont été plutôt séduits
par ce discours pourquoi est-ce que cela
n'a pas atteint votre votre cœur
puisquil a tenté de parler au cœur de la
droite aussi tout simplement parce que
il en faut plus pour mon cœur que des
punchline voyez et une punchline ça fait
pas une politique je pense que il
s'inscrit mais il peut pas faire autre
autement il dépend totalement d'uel
Macron le Premier ministre déjormais la
fonction a été totalement dissoute par
l'autorité verticale jupiterrienne mais
le problème est que s'inscrivant dans
les pas de Monsieur Macron il peut pas
assumer une rupture et donc il a proposé
quelques mesures par exemple sur la
santé l'ubérisation des pharmacies
l'ubérisation des pharmacies on a vu ce
que ça donnait au Canada c'est la
financiérisation et c'est la
désertification la taxe lapin très bien
on l'a voté au PS attendez c'est pas ce
qu'il fait là encore une fois une
réforme complète du système de santé
donc on peut aligner quelques mesures
dans lesquelles on pourrait se retrouver
mais aujourd'hui je l'ai dit la France
traverse un moment thélurique très très
grave seul un changement de principe
seul un changement de cadre avec de
nouvelles politiques et un nouveau
logiciel peut nous permettre justement
d'affronter l'avenir une mesure dans
laquelle vous vous retrouvez sans doute
pas c'est l'aide médicale d'État l'ame
on a entendu Gabriel qui a quasiment un
petit peu esquivé le sujet devant le
Sénat au aujourd'hui alors qu'hier il
avait bien parlé de passer par voie
réglementaire avant l'été que lui
répondez-vous sur ce sujet dans tout son
discours il était long pourtant il
aurait eu le temps d'en parler la partie
la plus faible c'est le régalien c'est
la sécurité vraiment il y a pas du tout
de bouleversement de révolution pénale
que les Français appellent de leur vœux
je vous rappelle que 70 % des Français
trouvent que notre justice est trop
laxiste et puis bien sûr c'est
l'immigration très très peu évidemment
l'aide médicale d'État l'aide médicale
d'État ça passera non pas par la loi à
travers un vote du Parlement donc du
coup du Sénat mais ça va passer par la
voie règlementaire donc une fois de plus
on méprise le Sénat l'Assemblée et donc
le parlementabe B avait dit que ça
serait possible hein de passer par voir
règlementaire de son courrier qu'est-ce
qui reste du Sénat et du Parlement en
France on a des 493 à gogo on a des
ordonnances qui ne sont même plus
ratifiées et on a désormais un conseil
constitutionnel qui nous interdit de
respecter la Constitution française
uneoute dernière question Bruno
rotaillot livivg dans la Constitution
hier et bien la le projet de loi a été
adopté quasiment à l'unanimité à
l'Assemblée nationale Gabriel hatal a
dit qu'il avait confiance dans les
sénateurs dans les parlementaires pour
trouver un accord quelle sera votre
position la position aussi de votre
groupe ah non mais nous on se retrouve
totalement dans la position notre
président Gérard arché qui a dit 1 l'IVG
n'est pas menacé il y a un paradoxe
d'ailleurs l'IVG était même
constitutionnalisé par plusieurs
décisions du Conseil constitutionnel et
Monsieur Macron S presse à le
constitutionnaliser moi j'aurais
beaucoup mieux il faudrait aussi qu'il
modifie la Constitution pour permettre
aux Français de voter par la voix du
référendum sur la politique migratoire
qu'il qu'il souhaite donc un
malheureusement euh il y aura sans doute
bon nombre de débat mais la position de
Géral arché est la bonne c'est-à-dire
que on ne peut pas mettre dans la
Constitution beaucoup beaucoup de de
droits sociétaux sociaux ça n'est pas un
catalogue d'ailleurs Simon veille non
mais il y aura un débat mais Simon
veille avait dit elle-même même en 2008
je crois lorsqu'elle présidait le comité
de consultatif pour le le préambule de
la Constitution qu'elle n'y était pas
elle- même favorable donc voilà nous
voterons nous débattrons et nous
voterons voilà bien merci beaucoup Bruno
retaillot d'avoir répondu à mes question
sur ce discours de politique générale au
Sénat on en écoute un petit un petit
extrait tout à l'heure lorsque Gabriel
Attal tout à l'heure a fait un véritable
déclaration d'amour c'est un classique
au
Sénat lorsque le Sénat est faible la
République est faible lorsque le Sénat
est fort la République est forte et
lorsqu'il n'y a
pas et lorsqu'il n'y a et lorsqu'il n'y
a pas de Sénat il n'y a plus de
République et une nouvelle réaction à
celle du président du groupe socialiste
au Sénat Patrick canner bonsoir on vient
d'entendre Gabriel hatal qui a fait une
déclaration d'amour au Sénat au début de
son discours mais il ne vous a pas
répondu lors de sa brève réponse de
cette 8 minutes ça vous déçoit écoutez
déjà il a fait une déclaration d'amour
au Sénat et surtout à la droite
sénatoriale dont il a besoin pour faire
passer ses réformes injustes et souvent
conservatrice pour pas dire
réactionnaire donc il y a pas de
surprise en la matière mais pour cet
homme qui se dit jeune moderne respecte
d'institution le fait qu'il réponde dans
sa déclaration finale à tous les groupes
de droite et pas un mot il a un petit
mot pour Marie scarer que oui mais bon
voilà un petit mot mais Marie scarer
fait pas partie entre guillemets du pôle
des trois groupes de gauche ça serait
donc je je le regrette je dire c'est pas
c'est pas très correct euh voilà c'est
un petit signe al c'est vrai que nous
avons été les plus critiques de sa
politique mais il aurait pu dire tout
simplement bah écoutez vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec ma politique mais je vous
respecte il aurait pu au moins dire ça
je suis déçu déçu d'ailleurs aussi sur
le fond du discours parce que
finalementoui comment vous qualifiez ce
discours macroniste de droite d'abord
tout d'abord c'est un discours de
répétition puisque hier nous avons eu à
peu près le même discours et même au mot
près dans beaucoup de de circonstances
donc venir au Sénat pour répéter ce que
nous avons entendu hier de manière très
plate de Monsieur Bruno lemè j'aurais
vraiment espéré qu'il y ait beaucoup
plus de choses sur les collectivités
territoriales sur la vision de la
décentralisation rien ou quasiment rien
non c'est décevant c'est décevant pour
les sénateurs donc pour la chambre des
collectivités territoriales oui vous
avez été déçu il n'y avait pas assez sur
ce sujet des collectivités il a été
question de des préfets de la vision
pluriannuelle des préfets de plus de
sévérité à l'égard des agresseurs d'élus
locaux il a parlé de déconcentration il
a parlé du poids de l'État
essentiellement dans les territoires
mais pas de la place des élus donc un un
discours pour moi très faible sur cette
cette dimension que nous attendions au
Sénat vous estimez qu'il a réellement
viré à droite Bruno rotillo ne
l'entendait pas de cette oreille tout à
l'heure non non non il a pas viré à
droite il est de droite je dire il a pas
de virage c'est la continuité de cette
politique depuis des années moi j'ai
évoqué le printemps social libéral de
2017 d'Emmanuel Macron et puis après
voilà tout a montré que ce soit la loi
retraite ou la loi immigration on voit
bien non pas ce virage de droite c'est
la confirmation de l'ancrage à droite de
la majorité présidentielle qui cherche à
élargir sa majorité avec la droite quoi
de plus normal et moi je j'invite
vraiment les gens de gauche sincères qui
pensent encore que la macronie voà c'est
un entre deux non c'est plus ni un entre
deux ni un en même temps c'est à droite
et à droite votre regard sur l'aide
médicale d'État qui est l'une des
sources pour le coup et bien de
désaccord entre LR et le gouvernement
elle sera réformée mais ça sera par voie
règlementaire et en s'appuyant sur sur
et bien le rapport Evin stéphanini
Claude Evin ancien ministre socialiste
écoutez dans cette maison s'est déroulé
à l'époque de Louis XI la fameuse
journée des dupes et bien oui LR est
aujourd'hui complètement le DUP de cette
affaire ils ont négocié ils espéraent un
soutien du gouvernement sur leur
position concernant la me une grande loi
qui aurait marqué les esprits ça va
passer par voie réglementaire voilà
souvent je m'interroge qui est la
marionnette qui est le marionnettiste on
sa depuis pas mal maintenant de jours
que le marionnettiste c'est Emmanuel
Macron et les marionnettes les idiots
utiles ce sont nos collègues de LR qu'il
continuent comme ça je ne sais pas si ça
va durer moi j'espérais un discours très
dur de Monsieur rotillot pour dire son
opposition par rapport à
rachidti par rapport à la loi
immigration en fait on a vu plutôt un
toutou et je pense que les vrais
discours d'opposition sont venus de la
gauche vous parlez de Rachid hadti un
mot sur la loi PLM Paris Lyon Marseille
pour le coup c'est un sujet sur lequel
on a eu un petit peu plus de détails
aujourd'hui par rapport à hier Gabriel
Atal qui annonce une loi d'ici la fin de
l'année bien pour réformer le mode de
scrutin de ces villes he qui n'est pas
qui ne sont pas des villes comme les
autres pour les élections municipales
est-ce que c'est légitime de et bien
revoir ce mode d'élection je lui
souhaite bien du plaisir quand il
expliquera aux Parisiens aux Marseillais
aux Lyonnais que leurs arrondissements
vont disparaître parce que c'est c'est
bien ça dont il s'agit c'est la
disparition des arrondissements et donc
de la démocratie de proximité représenté
par les maires d'arrondissement qu'il
soit de droite ou de gauche parce que
l'élection classique qui existe en
France du maire à partir du conseil
municipal élu par les citoyens ce n'est
pas celle effectivement de ces trois
villes ces trois villes ont un statut
particulier et qui fonctionne bien la
démocratie de proximité au travers des
arrondissements c'est une chose
intéressante et on pourrait même
peut-être plutôt le le développer sur
d'autres grandes villes françaises
d'autres grandes mé
donc ils ont tout
faux a derrière qu' a derrière on a
acheté madame rachti au travers madame
rachti on achète monsieur Sarkozi et
pourquoi pas Monsieur B Boret voilà tout
ceci voilà c'est c'est copains et coquin
maisélection de Rach candid àimagine pas
un seul instant que la question de Paris
n'est pas été dans la négociation dans
la venue de madame Rachida Datti qui
d'ailleurs l'a dit elle-même au moins
les cache elle dit la vérité monsieur
Macron se lui se cache en disant je n'ai
pas parlé de Paris quand j'ai demandé à
Madame Dati de rentrer et d'ailleurs
sans prévenir son premier ministre ça
vous montre où est le vrai pouvoir le
pouvoir n'est pas j Matignon il est au
château bien merci merci beaucoup
Patrick Kenner pour cette interview
cette réaction à ce discours de
politique générale qui a eu lieu au
Sénat lors duquel et ben Gabriel hatal a
également dit qu'il était prêt à
travailler avec la chambre haute écoutez
m'adresser à vous c'est aussi affirmer
la volonté du gouvernement de travailler
et de construire en commun au sein de
mon équipe pourtant la plus resserrée de
la 5e République je compte un ancien
sénateur avec Christophe Béchu un
sénateur actuel aujourd'hui au
gouvernement avec Sébastien le cor nu je
compte des maires qui savent
l'engagement la passion mais aussi les
contraintte qu'exige ce
mandat et je suis avec le président du
groupe les indépendants au Sénat Claude
maluret
bonsoir vous êtes intervenu comme les
autres présidents de groupe tout à
l'heure dans l'hémicycle vous avez dit
le temps des anathèmes est terminé vous
appelez à une forme d'union des
raisonnable j'allais dire contre le
rassemblement national une union des
raisonnable une union raisonnable euh on
va avoir des élections européennes dans
quelques mois on va voir la
présidentielle évidemment un peu plus
tard et aujourd'hui on voit bien que le
le danger d'extrême gauche est en train
de disparaître parce que la nupesse a
explosé parce qu'elle est fills se
suicide un peu plus tous les jours donc
ce n'est plus votre priorité le dernier
moment étant le 7 octobre dernier avec
la pire des inominies c'est-à-dire
l'excuse du Hamas et cetera donc je
pense que cette partie de l'extrémisme
est en train de perdre énormément de
terrain et que par par rapport aux idées
parce que leur programmes sont en fait
très voisins à quelques détails près et
surtout leur leur
sensibilité et est proche la porosité
fait qu'à chaque fois que plus l'extrême
gauche affaiblit plus l'extrême droite
se renforte et aujourd'hui tout le monde
le voit tout le monde le dit c'est pas
une surprise le problème c'est le Front
national le problème c'est d'éviter à
tout prix que en mai 2027 sur notre
écran de télévision à 20h euh s'affiche
un visage qu'on n' pas du tout envie de
voir et qui serait dangereux pour le
pays donc si on veut éviter ça on peut
pas continuer les querelles de cours
d'école on peut pas continuer les
querelles de chapelle on peut pas
continuer les anathèmes il faut que le
camp de la raison le camp des
raisonnables donc le camp de la raison
c'est-à-dire tous les modérés qui soit
de de
de ça va du centre gauche à la droite
républicaine il faut qu'elle trouve les
moyens soit d'une majorité de
au socialistes par exemple vous englobez
le Parti socialiste je j'englobe tous
ceux qui pensent tous ceux qui sont
démocrates et qui pense qu'on peut soit
faire des alliances soit faire une
majorité si vous n'imaginez enfin je ne
pense pas que vous puissiez imaginer que
pendant encore 3 ans on vive les
psychodrames qu'on vécu qu'on a vécu
depuis un an avec une absence de
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale donc
soit les modérés comprennent qu'ils
prennent un risque et il faudra pas
qu'ils se plaignent en 2027 d'avoir
perdu l'élection et d'avoir pas su la la
gagner soit ils comprennent ça et ils
arrivent d'une façon ou d'une autre
alliance majorité ou autes il a
différentes moyens la 5e République
donne beaucoup de de de flexibilité mais
sinon nous nous préparons des lendemains
difficiles et donc moi j'appelle à la
responsabilité vous appz par exemple à
une grande alliance électorage pour les
européennes par exemple où l'on voit que
le RN paraît si haut qu'est-ce que vous
qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez je pense
que les européennes je je crois j'ai
l'impression aujourd'hui qu'on n' pas
encore complètement identifié le danger
et moi je pense que c'est le lendemain
des élections européennes quand on verra
les résultats à 20h des élections
européennes que tout le monde se dira et
tant mieux après tout que tout le monde
se dira bon bah cette fois-ci on a bien
on a on a même plus le sondage on a le
sondage en vraie grandeur et que là je
pense que les habitudes risqueent de
changer moi je j'appelle à ce qu'elle
change parce que si on narrive pas à se
mettre d'accord le gouvernement sera
empêché il ne pourra pas
travailler l'ambiance sera la même que
celle qui a duré pendant toute l'année
2023 et 2027 s'annonce s'annonce mal
donc moi pour moi ma priorité
aujourd'hui c'est l'alliance du camp de
la raison alors vous avez entendu
Gabriel Atal tout à l'heure d'ailleurs
qui a rendu hommage à votre discours de
responsabilité également à celui d'Hervé
Marseille mais il a considérer que celui
de Bruno retaillot avait été bien
différent si LR se positionne
différemment de vous est-ce que cela
risque et bien de de casser la majorité
sénatoriale oh je pense pas
qu'aujourd'hui il y ait un problème
majeur de majorité sénatoriale bien
entendu il peut il peut se poser et
d'ailleurs il s'est posé à deux reprises
cette année sur des lois importantes sur
les retraites sur une partie du texte
sur les retraites et sur une partie du
texte immigration donc on voit bien que
la majorité elle est pas absolu et
d'ailleurs heureusement et d'ailleurs
heureusement on est en démocratie et par
conséquent ça risque de se ça risque de
se reproduire et puis deuxièmement quand
on parle de majorité sont donc de la
majorité lruc il faudrait déjà savoir
sur un certain nombre de points que
pense le parti LR lui-même est-ce que le
parti LR au Sénat est d'accord avec le
parti all l'air à l'Assemblée là aussi
les divergences ont été sur ces deux
textes pas évident là aussi c'est la
démocratie mais je pense en tout cas que
l'ensemble des euh des des démocrates du
centre gauche au Républicain ont intérêt
à cesser leur querelle de cours d'école
très franchement parce que la situation
devient préoccupante merci merci
beaucoup Claude maluret d'être venu
répondre à mes questions lors de cette
édition spéciale qui a été consacrée à
ce discour de politique générale au
Sénat de Gabriel hatal merci également à
Quentin calm qui m'a accompagné tout au
long de cette